oh man it's just one of those days
youtube wasn't letting us create the
stream for some reason
and so we had to keep trying to recreate
it so you got to put a title and you got
to put the description and do all this
work
and then we're like okay go and then
youtube goes deleted no
and then we're like uh okay refresh try
again and the same thing happens and i'm
just like oh
geez dude oh man well it's a crazy crazy
time out there man we're hearing some
restaurants in l.a are being forced to
shut down because
some of their fully vaccinated staff
members have contracted
breakthrough cases of covid there is a
story going around mitch mcconnell
insinuating the lockdowns will be coming
back because enough people are not
getting vaccinated
and at the same time for some reason
they're letting
people just walk through the border in a
viral video
you literally just see illegal
immigrants escorted through the border
with cbp standing there you know waving
hey come on
in it's amazing they're saying over 300
plus either people or groups i'm not
sure if they're saying groups
the local journalist said the group was
seen coming through over 300 plus seen
earlier today so maybe he means people
but i mean they're just
welcoming people in at a time when
there's a 900 surge in coveted cases
among the illegal immigrants that are
that are coming through the border so
if if they're saying that lockdowns are
looming because of the rise in these
cases
and then they're letting in tons of
people who have coveted
either they're really really dumb or
intentionally bringing about
yeah coveted lockdowns but we'll get
into that and we also also talk a bit
about critical race theory because
there was some error i guess apparently
the bite administration was pushing some
anti-whiteness and then got questioned
on it and they're like uh
yeah no we should not have done that and
so now they're walking things back and
we're going to be talking about this
with kenny shu who is the author of an
inconvenient minority and presumably a
self-described inconvenient minority
is that is that a fair assessment
perfectly fair
all right um yeah do you want to just
give a quick introduction to who you are
what you do yeah yeah so i
am the author of the new book an
inconvenient minority
the attack on asian american excellence
and the fight
for meritocracy um i talk about this
value
about of meritocracy that our culture is
increasingly losing because it
increasingly wants to treat people on
the basis of their race
and not on the basis of the content of
their character so what do we lose
when we penalize asian american success
or just
american success because it's not just
about asian americans it's about anybody
who
works hard studies hard tries to be
successful
and uh what do we do when we penalize
the excellent well i talk about that in
my book an inconvenient minority
i think we'll just end up like a bunch
of the american society and the global
society will just be a bunch of really
really dumb people
it'll be like idiocracy and i'm not even
joking right
you take away meritocracy and people
earn things not based on merit but based
on identity it's like
what are they doing it's like it's like
sorting chickens you know what i mean
like oh these ones gotta go over there
and these gotta over there and it's just
like
what in it how does that help humanity
in any way yeah absolutely you wanna
watch a very hapless and boring sports
game
get some of the most mediocre people and
make them start you know it's like it's
like that's south park episode remember
it's our castle
where like the kids that were like they
were playing with balloons or whatever
and they were wearing bras and stuff
like that
no yeah yeah so uh we'll get into this
stuff we got we got we got ian syndrome
yeah
we're in a weird shirt yeah this is i
thank you tim i'm glad you approved
this very interesting because a lot of
excellence when you when you
put people into a meritocracy follows
along i think the pareto distribution
and jordan peterson was talking about
this that you have very very few people
at the very
top and you can see this throughout
almost all of human culture
the only place where it seems to fail is
money because
money gets passed down so you get these
people that are born into extreme
amounts of wealth and so there's a bit
of a
merit meritocracy imbalance when it
comes to wealth
yeah i mean that's totally true i mean
and you know it's funny because
our elite right now um people are
fighting over these
scarce elite prestigious positions at
places like
harvard university and and now you know
people are a lot of these ambitious
people
feel like they have to be a part of some
victim category
in order for them to have a shot at a
place like harvard or a shot at a place
like a prestigious arts fellowship or
you know a guggenheim or something like
that
and it's funny because you see this and
now you have one out of six
people in gen z one out of six
generations
ears think that they are lgbtq
plus which is an interesting thing if
you think about it because
you know we know that biologically
speaking
that is much higher than the ratio of
people biologically who
would be lgbtq plus so you're saying
that's like a social component so
there's a social component there's a
reason why people tend to identify
in that direction people actually want
to identify now as victim categories
because it does give them these
unearned privileges i think a lot of
people have pointed it out too just
set claim underprivileged status i think
it was
brown university that allowed people to
identify as a minority if they so choose
yeah well we'll get into all that we got
lydia president i am in the corner i'm
sorry my cool shirt can't compete with
ian's cool shirt i'm a little bit
jealous
and i just wanted to say that abigail
schreier talks about the social
component of like making this a cool
thing and especially among young women
it's a huge problem it's an issue
before we get started my friends head
over to eat right
and feelwell.com what a beautiful url
it's in the the link is in the
description below and you can get 51
off your keto elevate c8 mct
oil powder all of these big fancy words
medium chain
triglyceride i'll tell you that what it
really means it's very simple is that
this is the good stuff in terms of
giving you
healthy energy so ian every night he
sprinkles a little bit of that in his
coffee
i put a little bit more in tonight and
man i almost finished it
how else is good how else would ian of
all people have the energy
to go two and a half to three hours on a
podcast
were it not for his trusty biotrust
found over at eat write and feelwell.com
51 off
and they say you get a 60-day money-back
guarantee
keto elevate provides your body only c8
the most ketogenic mct in its purest
form
in the purest form that means it
provides very fast and effective support
for enhanced energy levels
healthy appetite management enhanced
mental clarity and focus
athletic performance i mean all of
that's just easily explaining ian's
performance absolutely keto elevate is
very gentle on your stomach
five grams of the highly sought after
mctc8
per scoop keto elevate is the most
advanced mct powder on the market today
and you get free shipping on every order
and for every order today biotrust
donates a nutritious meal to a hungry
child in your honor
through their partnership with no kid
hungry.org to date biotrust has provided
over 4.4 million meals to hungry kids
please help biotrust hit their goal of 5
million meals this year
and as this is this is always the
craziest one you get free vip
live health and fitness coaching from
biotrust's team of expert nutrition
and health coaches for life with every
order dude seriously
grab a bag of this stuff make some
smoothies give them a call and ask them
what you can do to better improve your
health and fitness
and they will give you the free new
e-report the top 14 ketogenic foods with
every order so go to
eatrightandfeelwell.com 51 off thank you
so much biotrust for sponsoring the show
but don't forget
we have this wonderful new website
timcast.com
and when you become a member there you
get access to exclusive member
episodes of the tim cast irl podcast
which go up every night monday through
thursday around 11 p.m
and you'll be supporting our great
fearless and intrepid journalists of
which we are hiring more and more and
more
we got a bunch of people coming out this
weekend we've got some i believe we've
got the dnd people coming out so we're
going to be doing
we're going to be doing a dungeons and
dragons style
show that is tracking politics and so
we create these campaigns that are
similar to things that are happening in
the political space this is the idea so
far
and then we have different people
playing we'll experience these things
and have to make choices
and we'll see what choices would they
make and this is where we really learn
about people
you see is ian truly an authoritarian or
is he actually a kind-hearted hippie
i'm gonna play a neutral half-orc
neutral half-orc that's fine
we'll see what happens chosen but don't
forget to like this video subscribe to
this channel
share the show with your friends if you
really like it if you're listening on a
podcast or whatever
then you can give us five stars and all
that good stuff let's jump into this
first story and just talk about what's
been going on with these lockdowns
la restaurants are forced to close amid
rise in covid 19 cases
as california chronovirus
hospitalizations hit highest point since
march
the daily mail reports some la
restaurants that have prevailed through
the pandemic lockdowns are now closing
their doors as cases rise
mainly due to the indian delta coveted
variant
it comes as they all see an increase in
cases and california has seen infections
rise
to 5063 per day or a 160
increase from 1 900 wait what is this oh
i'm sorry from 1946 two weeks ago
bottega louis and the village idiot have
posted on their instagram pages about
closing
the village idiot said it closed because
a fully vaccinated staff member was
diagnosed with the virus
at least seven counties in california
making up more than half the state's
residents are urging residents to wear
masks indoors
california's hospitalizations due to
cover 19 have more than doubled in the
last month
according to the la times now uh you may
get you guys
may have heard la they're doing
mandatory masks indoors las vegas says
we get this
on tuesday chicago mayor lori lightfoot
suggested she may
may she may make masks mandatory
like la as cases increase 164
in a month from 34 per day to 90 per day
and they're going to say it's it's
they're blaming this on delta but let me
let me highlight something else
mitch mcconnell warns there could be
lockdowns if americans don't get
vaccinated
as the delta variant continues to wreak
havoc i wish you to come out and say man
it is going to be incredibly difficult
to convince people
that they should get the vaccine if
we're hearing at the same time they're
planning lockdowns
regardless of the vaccine so i whenever
we talk about this stuff you know what
we say go talk to your own doctor
yeah you know it's really crazy though
we're watching all this stuff happen
there's a lot of stuff we'll get into in
a minute too especially with like
the economy you know joe biden's town
hall
for some reason it has now become
i guess uh uh on the left
anti-vaxxer to say talk to a doctor
about what's right for you so yeah so
there was there was a post by uh
casey neistat cool dude big fan right
i've known him for a while he's cool
dude
and he just put get vaccinated and i
said no talk to your doctor okay
like don't be so absolute yes you'll
probably end up being advised to get a
vaccine i'm not saying don't get
vaccinated i'm saying
talk to a doctor a lot of people say
like oh my doctor's not smart or i don't
trust my doctor it's like okay get a
better doctor
yeah if i if i invited a plumber to my
house and i was like my toilet's clogged
and he was like i recommend
smashing it with a sledgehammer i'd be
like bro are you a plumber or not like
i'm gonna find a plumber who's gonna be
like i will fix your toilet you know
what i mean so anyway look
right i said go to a doctor
ask them you know just five minutes not
even just hello doc
what do you think you know here's my age
here's my my history the doctor says
well here's what i think
but for some reason i am getting
attacked by a ton of people who are like
that's anti-vaxxer
they're like why be so dumb it's
actually against the rules
on youtube to tell people not to go to a
doctor
this is the point we're at right now
where regardless of the news
regardless of what's going on with
lockdowns you have i guess vaccine
zealotry
of like just let the strange man come to
your door knock on your door and give
you a vaccine it's like
well yeah but you know if if they do
call your doctor and say
what do you think apparently that's bad
now i guess that's where we're at
wow you know it's it's it's crazy
because you have these
the government-imposed lockdowns right
and they said
um we are doing this for your your
benefit your safety but then they're
taking away all of control you know
they're taking away your freedom to be
able to
um you know go where you want and do
these kinds of things basically this
virus and they're basically taking away
your own ability to
to to accurately judge for yourself you
know what the best thing is that works
for you
it's it's almost like you know i don't i
don't even know what to say i really
don't i was genuinely surprised because
people responded to me and they were
like
you're so dumb like i get inundated with
these tweets where they're like you're
dumb
and they're like the doc will just tell
you to get the vaccine and i'm like so
what's the problem
like seriously here's here's my here's
what i'm here's what bothers me right
we have the vaccine adverse event
reporting system
all right and they recently like added
more numbers to it and there's like a
point
zero zero three six uh um i think it's
point zero zero three seconds i don't
get the numbers wrong youtube will get
mad at me but it's like a very
very very very low amount of reported
deaths from uh
in varus and okay so here's what i'm
thinking i'm like okay
what if we could reduce those numbers by
making sure that people talk to a doctor
before they just went out to one of
these you know centers
or before this had to get vaccinated
yeah because let's let's say there's
somebody who would normally have a
counterindication or
an allergy and you've got all the
celebrities in the world you've got
people like casey neistat and they're
telling people just go do it
and casey's response to me was that he
went to a parking lot waited 45 minutes
stuck his arm out the window and then
they said carry on good sir and i'm like
would you talk to a doctor first like
i'm like even even at these places they
want you to fill out the form to make
sure not any allergies or anything like
that
if we could get people to simply be like
hey here's my history
and then the doc said in that rare rare
instance
oh hey wait what's that you've got
you've got a glycol allergy or something
like that
well i'm going to go ahead and say don't
do it maybe we could reduce vares and
reduce actual uh
harm and vaccine hesitancy and then
maybe then we could actually solve this
problem but you know what man
the entire time we've been going through
this covet thing we're like chickens
running around with our kids that's the
thing
what we need to avoid is panic that is
the number one problem and i think we
talked about this in march of 2020 tim
you and i
the real danger that we face as a
society is panic
if we do this right and we and we do it
safely
i think should be at least better i
would imagine
the best they can be bro i don't even
know anymore all right look there's a
video
there's a video of illegal immigrants
being just like walked through the
southern border
40 border patrol agents this year caught
covent
wow a 900 increase in covet cases among
illegal immigrants
and i'm just sitting here like bro i
don't i'm trying
look the people who watch this show are
not dumb people they're often correcting
us
they're like ten that's what you got
wrong get emails all the time and i'm
like oh that's a good point
how am i supposed to be like this this
voice of reason
when i'm like we really gotta you know
everyone's gotta pitch in go to your
doctor make sure you
find out what's right for you and if you
can't get that vaccine and then they're
like but tim
they're just opening the security gates
and walking people through that are sick
and i'm like man i don't know what to
tell you
even more reason to be careful and focus
talk to doctors and
and do things take care of your own
health that's first and foremost you
know what's really funny is i i think i
figured out exactly why they're mad
about the talk to your doctor thing
because it's like deontology versus
utilitarianism which i reference every
so often
and it's the the collective left are
very much like
for the collective good the needs of the
money out with the needs of the few
right whereas deontology is it's very
kind of broad but the general idea is
you know
each each action has its own action
right don't take immoral actions
against an individual and you like it's
not so much about the outcome it's about
the action you take so
my attitude is kind of like i'm not i
wouldn't want to sacrifice anybody
to to any kind of risk factor
but i would also rather i would i also
recognize like okay there may be risks
you know what i mean
so how about we just make sure everyone
is as is as informed as possible so i
say
each individual don't get your advice
from people like me
you find a good doctor who knows a lot
about this you ask them specific
questions to to to make
sure that everything you're concerned
about with your health is covered and
then if they say you know here's what
you got to do
you take their advice if they prescribe
you something you say okay i do it all
the time
but they i think the left gets mad
because they're utilitarian
they don't want individuals to be
taken care of i guess they don't focus
on the act against the individual they
don't care they want the hard
numbers for the large group and the
percentages of people who get
shuffled under or left behind they don't
care about well that's that's
that that's a reasonable way the way
that you put it um but the funny thing
about what you just said
and then also what you said earlier
about the panic about all of these
lockdowns is that
and and the fact that they're now
closing these restaurant stores in
california
you know because somebody got the delta
variant of covet is that we already knew
based on the vaccine people's own data
that you could still get covid from the
vaccine
and then you know the covid may be less
effective but you could still die
so okay a person may be less effective
the vaccine may be less effective
so you know what you know you so
somebody
you know got hurt from covid from the
delta variant but that's still within
the realm
of possible outcomes it's still an
entirely reasonable alchemist
as to what happened and you shouldn't
make a completely panicked
move because of that you know what what
they're saying now is that
well for one they're saying almost all
of the cases and deaths are among people
who are not vaccinated
and we're still seeing a lot of stories
about people who are getting it and are
vaccinated but you know i always try to
tell people
be careful about what the media
highlights you know what i mean it's
this it's the scaling problem right
because there's so much media
and there's so many people of course if
you give out 360 million doses or
something like that 336
you're going to get a large amount of
adverse reactions
relatively large you know depending on
what your perspective is and then
news outlets are going to start
snatching that up and writing about
every single possible one so
it's that's why i might just talk to
your doctor because they might be like
look at this chart you know what i mean
right it's kind of um on the media not
to panic
society because these these these
shutdowns were
really only because we didn't want to
overload the hospitals in the beginning
and it was only going to be 15
days just to make sure we could handle
this mass what we thought would be a
mass
influx of patients which turned out i
think as far as i know we never really
had that
mass just you know hospital over
some places some places there are videos
of of like people who go around
they were going around during the height
of the pandemic and finding empty
hospitals
but i think people misunderstood that it
was like key areas were absolutely
overloaded
now as for you know new york we know
that
there were there were some patient
issues in hospitals in new york and so
cuomo decided he would just murder
people
instead of actually utilizing the mercy
or the javits center
so he was warned if you put sick people
in nursing homes you'll kill all these
old people and he was like whatever
because if you were to put them in the
mercy or the javits center which were i
think the mercy had like one
bed used and the javascript 30 so we we
did set up this great amazing center
like we're really worried about this and
he was like
did you ever find out why he didn't use
the hospitals i mean in my opinion it's
because it would have made trump look
really good
but but here's what they're saying
they're saying right now because um
because people didn't get vaccinated and
this i i'm not i'm not entirely sure if
this makes sense but this is what
they're saying
because people don't get vaccinated then
transmissibility
uh was was still running rampant between
people among people who were not
vaccinated
which resulted in mutations which
resulted in a
more resistant vaccine-resistant strain
which
somewhat reduces the efficacy of these
vaccines and now you're getting fully
vaccinated people who are getting sick
with delta because i think they said it
was like 88 percent
but the thing i i doesn't quite make
sense i'm not
i'm not quite sure that actually makes
sense because youtube actually has a
rule that you cannot say
the vaccine prevents covid like that's
actually in youtube's rulebook
so i'm like well if if the vaccine
wasn't ever 100
then people could still get covet it
could still mutate and still become
vaccine resistance i'm i'm not sure you
know what i mean
you know what look i don't i can't speak
to
the science on this one for sure we had
dr chris martin said on the show he made
his case in the members only podcast
but we did pull up scientific journals
like
studies that contradicted even what he
was saying and i'm like
you know people are going to pick and
choose what they trust and what they
want to believe plus you've got the
the censorship of communist youtube to
deal with i honestly have no idea
that's why i'm like don't don't come to
me for advice but i can't say one thing
when you're ushering people through the
border the biden administration
and not doing anything about it i don't
think they're serious at all i really
don't think they care
i am inclined to agree and you mentioned
earlier about them being utilitarian
but i'm not sure that you can look at
the way that those texas democrats left
the state with zero masks and who are
now going back and spreading copen among
their own people
and i don't think that you can look at
the border and say that they actually
truly care
about the good of the whole when they're
actively promoting policies that make it
possible for
what 900 increases in coveted cases at
the border that's absolute insanity to
me
they don't care they don't so when mitch
mcconnell's like we're going to go back
to the way
things were in 2020 it's like well i
guess so because not like anybody in the
government has
any idea what's going on when we said
the 900 increase of border
covet cases is that like gone from one
to nine
or is that like no it's like it was like
14 to 190 something or whatever okay
okay yeah now to be fair to be fair
that's a good point ian yeah because we
did see a hundred and eighty eight
thousand people cross the border this
month alone
yeah i haven't we've already hit a
million this year uh
so far it's only june and by the end of
the year we're going to have 2 million
so it's exciting so 180 000 you said
across the border 88 i think and 180
cases out of 188 000 people
uh i'm not entirely sure if that's of
all
if that number is pertaining to all of
the people who came through
be healthy friends yeah yeah check this
out
we got the story from timcast.com okay
we gotta be careful on this one because
i don't know if i can read this quote
from joe biden it's against youtube's
rules
i'll read it anyway and tell you um
before i do joe biden the president
is giving medical misinformation if i
were to assert what joe biden said
youtube would delete this video as per
youtube's rules
joe biden falsely claims you're not
gonna get coveted
if you have been vaccinated that is not
true
absolutely not true we've already seen
breakthrough cases
people who are vaccinated against
getting sick i think it was um
was it uh uh bill maher oh mario yeah he
was vaccinated they didn't
cancel his show now we have restaurants
shutting down um
joe biden the president of the united
states is is is espousing
medical misinformation my friends uh so
this is for
timcast.com we say i guess we put we we
say we now because not they
during a town hall on wednesday night
president biden claimed that people who
have received vaccines will not get
covet 19
after fully vaccinated white house
officials have recently been infected
with the virus oh yeah
he said quote the various shots that
people are getting now cover that
you're okay you're not gonna get covered
if you have these vaccinations that is
wrong
that's wrong youtube see you heard us
we're saying joe biden is incorrect and
joe biden the president and the white
house
are giving medical misinformation and
bad information we're doing what you
want us to do youtube sensors
abundant statements come after multiple
fully vaccinated democrat lawmakers and
witness officials
have become infected with the virus
beginning with the texas democrats who
fled their state
to stop legitimate democratic processes
the texas democrats first met with a
pelosi staffer who became infected
so now i think the latest we saw was
like a handful of white house staffers
there i i don't think the texas
democrats are going to give any more
updates on how many of their delegations
stopped
yeah because it was it was like 11 of
their delegation had already
become you know coveted positive and now
you know joe biden goes on cnn
and he gives this bunk information i'm
wondering if youtube is going to ban
biden over this
you know they twitter banned trump i
mean trump was relentless and i don't
know how much
how many tweets did he put out that were
wrong well wrong about what i don't know
just
misinformation i guess would you say
countless countless 10
20 100 i mean i don't know i wasn't
following you know
i'll tell you this you look at twitter
you look at joe biden you look at trump
and it's just like static it's like
looking at an old tv
i if you guys are out there listening
don't ban him for this
don't ban joe biden for saying this
thing i mean he
acknowledged that maybe it's wrong maybe
put a thing on there that
how much how how how long until like you
know fauci comes out and actually says
oh actually
you know cdc guy like joe biden was
right the whole time apparently he's not
no bananas joe biden is wrong it's the
weirdest thing so there was a study from
oxford
talking about a particular medication i
won't say because youtube
oh my gosh it's ridiculous yeah and uh
uh
i emailed google like
in order to talk about this do i have to
say that oxford is wrong
and the science is wrong and they were
like just make sure you provide adequate
context and i'm like i don't believe you
like the rules explicitly say that you
can't say there's certain treatments for
kovid
but oxford came out the study saying
they may there may may
and i'm like i can't even talk about
that so i love i love the the sheer
absurdity that is youtube
back when all of this first started i
did a video about it
it was when everything was going crazy
in wuhan and it wasn't spreading
anywhere else
and youtube actually demonetized that
and they told me no
you can't talk about this and i was like
it's news you know what i mean it's
really weird
and then like a couple weeks later like
okay actually yeah you can't talk about
it and i was like okay
so this this is the problem with
censorship that these big tech platforms
do
by choosing you know to to with like
to ban certain information it's very
likely because they're not experts
soon that information will actually turn
to be correct or important
and then they've had ban they've banned
it and we got to go back and change it
yeah that's that's that's that's where
we're at with communist america and big
tech and youtube
so i don't know the information war is
upon us i used to think that was more of
a
more of a an allegory or is that the
right word for it uh
i would i would say it was it sounded
like hyperbole when alex jones was first
talking about it but i think it's a good
assessment that is 100 an information
war that fifth generational warfare
we're seeing now
i love being able to have a debate about
an idea where one person has bad
information and the other person is able
to correct them and you can see the
process because then other people that
have the bad information also get to be
part of that process
right so that's why i'm i'm turned off
by you know censoring things that are
wrong or
i i want to make sure i'm being fair to
joe biden because
it may not be that he's wrong okay it
may just be that he doesn't know how to
put
words together that is true oh yeah so
in another story
i don't know if you guys watched the
town hall this is uh from the daily mail
they say quote the experts say we know
that this virus is
in fact uh um uh it's gonna be
or excuse me biden loses his thoughts on
vaccines flubs answer on his foreign
policy work
and falsely tells all town hall you
won't get coveted if you have the shot
that is incorrect
can't watch so i i think the dude just
isn't isn't with it you know
i think most people realize that by now
help me
[Laughter]
look i mean obviously we know you know
we know what joe biden's
strengths and weaknesses particularly
weaknesses are right now at this
advanced age stage of his presidency
i mean i was always of the belief that
kamala harris
is really running a lot of the show on
joe biden especially with regards to his
racial policy his equity policy
everything like that
i mean say what you want about joe biden
being ineffective but all that does is
that makes kamala harris
and her agenda even more effective well
so
so you know your book is about
meritocracy yeah
and i don't even i'm we're sitting here
like we know that you have this book and
talking about stuff and i can only
assume you probably don't like joe biden
but i don't know i mean maybe you love
the guy but you hate critical race
theory
wow i mean i look joe biden here's the
thing
he he did something he he was he was the
candidate that was able he was the only
candidate the democrats could run
that was able to win back the trump
voters i was able to win back some of
the trump voters that that's that that's
what i think about joe biden and he did
isn't it crazy
so we lost white men yeah yeah you know
trump
won more hispanics
more asians more black people
than than he did in 2016 you know this
supposed racist everything like that won
all of these groups
more effectively the only place that the
polls the exit polls show he lost was
white men
[Laughter]
what do you think about regarding
meritocracy is you've written a book on
it and and the fact that we have
a government or at least the top of our
government the president where we vote
people in based on popularity
not necessarily merit and
so i want to know well there's merit in
there isn't there not necessarily you
can have some dumb idiot that everyone
loves that becomes president
doesn't have any idea what they're doing
because he's the most popular well
that's the thing is that's what some
people think about trump
they think he's just a dumb idiot but i
think he has genuine merit
he is probably the most effective
marketing
sales person that we have you know that
i've ever seen
in my lifetime on the campaign trail
you're saying that he is the the
greatest president of all time
i'm saying he's the greatest marketing
strategist of all time
yeah do you think there's something we
could do better with our government so
that we could get
more merit at the top well you know they
they
here's the thing about our political
system and and this and this this
correlates kind of with meritocracy
um i i take different definitions of
merit so i don't think that the person
who wins the president should be the
person with the most degrees or the
person who's
supposedly done the most for our country
or whatever
the person has to really connect with
the people and i think that our system
our political system
flawed as it is still gives the people
the ability
to to make judgments on themselves uh
you know to choose the president
and i think that that that's worth
preserving so you think that
the president's main job is to connect
with the people not so much to be the
best or at any one thing
right i mean i mean the president
originally functioned he has a cabinet
and that's where he brings in all of the
best people and everything like that
that's his choice but he has to be able
to connect he's the executive
right the executive isn't necessarily
the smartest person in the room the
executive is the person
who can connect all of the dots and form
it into a larger vision
that's what trump did probably most
effectively he was able to create
that vision make america great again
keep america great 2016
that that that you resonated with
a segment of the populace the republican
party had historically
not been able to resonate with well i
think that is meritorious that's very
very
absolutely yeah and uh the one problem
was that
you know merit can go into a bunch of
different directions was trump able to
rally people
and and win an election yep does it show
merit of course less
you know hillary clinton had less she
lost however
when it came to actually administrating
trump didn't have it
and that's why he ended up for uh for a
variety of reasons i'll say one of the
reasons
he ended up not winning a re-election
though we'll see what happens next once
people realize that biden was actually
the worst choice
but um one of the problems was the
people he surrounded himself with mark
milley for instance
yeah this this is a guy that trump
should have gotten rid of a long time
ago
dr fauci trump didn't have he should
have fired these people
john bolton oh man he hired the guy he
still
showed his political neophyte instincts
when he chose rex tillerson as the
secretary of state i mean they obviously
could not connect from the very start
he started to be a little better towards
the end
in terms of his administrative picks but
you could tell at the very beginning he
was
he was he was too hewn to the republican
party and their instincts instead of
being able to go with what his vision
was
and that harmed him because he only has
four years you only have four years
president that's nothing
that's no time at all she over here does
not have four years xi jinping does not
have four years he has 30 years to do
whatever he wants and remake china's own
in his own is that how long it lasts 30
years no i mean and so you
you get deposed or you die or you retire
oh they get elected for life
you don't get elected for life but you
can you can
extend your supposed constitutional
authority however long you really want
to
are they appointed by the party they are
yes and it's like a group of people at
the top of the party decide uh-huh
yes yeah that that's yeah this is that's
a it's a totally different system
in china than it is in the u.s we we do
have some good news though
i mean it's kind of good news it's
actually kind of bad news but there's a
light at the end of the tunnel
there's you know door closes and a
window opens we got the story from
timcast.com
white house spins department of
education blames random error for
document promoting critical race theory
this fall
and we also saw jen sackey challenged on
this so the original story was that the
biden administration's guidelines for
schools reopening this fall is backing a
radical group's literature that promotes
anti-racism training in public
classrooms across the country now we've
got to break down that word
anti-racism because if you are unlearned
you may just
assume these code words these dog
whistles
just mean what it means on the surface
no anti-racism according to
ibram x kendi is racial discrimination
quite literally you think it's
anti-racism like people aren't going to
be arrested no no he wants them to
discriminate in the bases of race
what he's saying is that like he let's
put it this way
if racism is negative is is plus one
and not being racist is zero anti-racism
is negative one yes it is it is a value
in mirror image to racism
that serves the same function but for a
somewhat different ideology
that being what he claims is if we are
anti-racist meaning
we actually implement the exact same
policies of the past
but we do it it'll be better this time
and that just as far as i'm concerned
it's just literally racism
so the good news i suppose is that the
biden edmond has backtracked
after sparking a major backlash on
social media regarding critical ace race
theory
blaming a random error for a government
guy that promoted a far left group
and their agenda we have this from the
daily mail jensecki claims it was an
error to promote the group
that urges teachers to disrupt whiteness
and oppression
after republicans accuse the biden admin
of flip-flopping now this is good news
apparently the democrats are starting to
get scared of wokeness there was a story
in axios we saw the victory of eric
adams
in new york city they're worried they're
going to lose the midterms
because get well go broke yeah
yeah i mean it's it's funny you bring up
eric adams because he was
in new york city you would think oh um
there were a couple of really woke
candidates maya wiley was a was a big
vote candidate
in new york city and you would think oh
the the black americans and hispanic
americans would vote for the vote
candidate they didn't
they voted for the candidate eric adams
who promised
more police not less police he promised
public safety he said i'm going to make
crime my number one issue i'm going to
make education
as my my second best biggest issue
because the new york public system is
so poor and it's not because of funding
it's not because of what the teachers
unions say which is oh we need more
resources did you know
that new york city funds uh
funds students twenty eight thousand
dollars a year twenty-eight they spend
twenty eight thousand dollars a year
per student which is the highest in the
nation so it's not about funding
but uh eric adams you know said hey look
we need to restore the culture of these
schools so they actually voted
uh for in my opinion the candidate
that that um did that
that represented you know the least
excesses of wokeness
fortunately yeah and i'm not surprised i
mean we saw what happened in south texas
we saw what happened in in miami now of
course that was likely you know hispanic
individuals with experience with
communism and marxism
but uh the other day we had uh ricardo
and jose lamassan
and jose he's he's an older gentleman he
actually was in the anti-fidel castro
underground in cuba and he said he said
some scary stuff
he said that if black lives matter gets
real power they're going to kill people
he said that these people are marxist
they're they're enemies from within
they're scary and i'm like man this is a
guy
with to flee cuba because of what
happened
now that is freaky the difference
between cuba
and the united states however is that we
got several hundred million people here
right now we got what like a you know
170 or so million
active voters so these are a lot of
people that i don't think would allow
the the as you described it the axises
of wokism to
become too pervasive now what does it
mean to be too pervasive well let's be
fair
it's pervasive it's in institutions it's
in video games but i think people are
starting to recoil from this
that's why joe biden the administration
had to backtrack they're getting worried
i'm i'm hoping that's the case
i'm hoping they realize they are
poisoning their party with this stuff
i hope they're realizing they will lose
elections unless they get away from this
but i also have to add they're never
getting my vote back anyway
they've crossed they crossed the the
rubicon as it were
they went nuts like hardcore insane and
now they want to come back and be like
oh no
yeah nice try dude i'm not i'm not i'm
not gonna gonna play that game with
these people
you look at you look at new york you
look what people wanted they wanted the
ex-cop
eric adams right yeah and you know it's
it's funny because
during the campaign if you remember
biden
during the 2020 campaign biden was
pressured to say defund the police
and he he did not say defund the police
and i i'm convinced that
if he went and crossed that line and he
said
yeah we're going to go defund the police
i'm probably i'm convinced that
you know even more trump voters you know
even even
you know the voters that he supposedly
won back from trump would have
stayed with trump um yeah that would
have been would have been the
it would be it would be over right right
right but now unfortunately you can see
you can see of course promises where
made promises were not kept
um biden you know is growing old he's
growing senile he's letting kamala
harris take over more of his
administration
what promises were not kept well uh
this this idea of of biden saying that
he claims to be the unifier
the unifying candidate i will unify
america instead he's pushing divisive
race ideology
it's not even that he he said we he was
basically he basically was talking about
the divide in this country and how bad
it is first of all
he launched his campaign on a lie
charlottesville yep the the the very
fine people hoax
he just absolutely rammed that line on
people's throat because he's a scumbag
and now he says you know we need we need
to unify you know we need to come
together and it's like dude just went on
and gave a speech
where he said the republicans voting
legislation is the greatest threat since
the civil war
you want to talk about bombastic and
divisive language sure we can talk about
critical race theory
how about the president of the united
states coming up and saying the
republican agenda
is a bigger threat to the confederacy
that's what he literally said
dudes lost his mind yeah the central
banking system is more of a threat the
fiat currency the 28 trillion in
in national debt the runaway inflation
he's claiming it's not runaway it's like
kind of like
what was his exact words didn't you guys
remember off top of your head he was
like it's okay
it's just inflation it's going to get
back to normal he said something like
this will not increase inflation he said
that i think three times in a row
because he's super with it
as we all know um but i was like there's
no way that you can look at this and say
that inflation is not coming in fact
janet yellen has even said
yeah we expect some form of inflation
look we can survive inflation we can we
can make it past our milk costing more
money
and that it sucks i mean he's got no
solutions he's mocking these business
owners like he i
i believe he's essentially mocking them
but i'll tell you
we we can get through that and we can
argue about it combine
that combine a massive escalation in the
cost of food
with joe biden saying the republican
agenda is the greatest threat since the
civil war
this guy is flicking matches at a potter
keg
we talked about last night with jose
llamas about uh the cuban revolution
how castro betrayed the revolution and
essentially took it uh didn't didn't
install their their democracy and i
asked them what what could we have done
differently or what could they have done
differently in 1960 that would have
prevented he said not to
to be more patient not to take not to
revolt against batis because what they
thought was batista was running for
election again and they thought it was
going to be rigged
so they were like they had a preemptive
revolution to get this guy on office
before he could
so this i could see something like that
happening in this country with all this
divisiveness people thinking there's
election issues
that people would act impatiently and i
think it's
it's up to us to stay you know calm even
if the system seems flawed
that we you know remain and work within
the system you see
you see joe biden said the other day as
well that he wants to he's working to
ban
any weapon with the ability to take
multiple rounds yeah
wow huh he basically let's be real he
was not very
articulate but he wanted to say weapons
that can take multiple rounds like 20 30
40 50 120.
you don't need them and i'm working hard
to ban them and now i know a lot of
people on the left are going to try and
play this game i should i'm sorry i'm
sorry i'm gonna walk that back
i know a lot of the establishment
democrats because leftists actually like
guns
are gonna play this game where they're
like oh he didn't mean
banning every gun oh he meant this i
don't care what you
think he meant because y'all can't read
his mind he
said it yeah so if you're talking about
a weapon that can take a detachable
magazine
then you can have a variety of magazines
of sizes that's what he's talking about
the democrats have long said they want
to ban semi-automatic weapons
why should i believe biden meant
something else yeah don't take him at
his word i bring that up yeah because
one of the other things that jose
mentioned about cuba
was that fidel castro came out and said
the famous question guns
for what and everyone was like yeah for
what and then they throw their guns into
a pile and then
the communists took over and they got to
live under a boot for the next several
generations
yeah right yeah i mean
it's crazy i mean you know the funny
thing is you know you go to china
and china of course the communist party
um has a has a huge monopoly over the
arms
over arms and everything like that and
not only do they have a monopoly of arms
they
have increased their monopoly to
surveillance and
now they can surveil you you know for
for whatever thing so now they control
the arms
and they control you know your actions
they can control your thoughts
you know and they can incentivize you
based on your thoughts this is the whole
idea of like a social currency they have
a social currency system in china now
and it's like this is the direction that
we are progressing as a country
and people think oh it's just guns it's
not a big deal you know we just
you know that kind of thing that's what
progressives think but you realize that
guns is the linchpin it's the physical
linchpin that is able to defend all of
the rest of the rights that we hold so
dear
this is what the these uh these
establishment demons don't understand
right these establishment voters these
default libs
they're like you know joe biden says you
need an f-15 and nukes to go up against
the government that's not true
there's a reason why we don't have to a
certain degree
jack boot biden thugs kicking doors in
and dragging people out by their hair
especially over covet and lockdowns but
you do see things like that
in australia and new zealand and canada
and the uk
there's a reason uh why it's a little
better here it's not perfect we
absolutely do have cops will kick your
door in and then you know arrest you or
just shoot you
but the thing is the fact that so many
americans have guns makes it extremely
difficult to violate human rights
because you never know if you're going
to encounter someone who's going to be
able to defend themselves
it equalizes a little bit of the power
between the government and the
individual
so that they have to go through the
proper motions it's not hard for a
government to oppress you using
bureaucracy it's actually very easy
however gun ownership protects you
a little bit and in the in the long run
if done properly can protect a nation
forever so long as you don't end up with
people saying the stupid question guns
for what which is what they're doing
over and over and over what do you need
a gun for we need a gun for and i'm like
none of your business who cares
i don't need to give you an answer i i
think the founding fathers kind of put
uh the second amendment into place
because they expected the government to
grow and grow and grow
as governments do like they would talk
about were not a bunch of men governed
by angels were men governed by men
they understood the shortcomings they're
like okay the government's gonna grow
we need to kind of put citizens on a
slightly more even playing field and
that was unique
like you didn't see that in cuba when
this is going on you didn't see that in
mao's china
this is something that we need to pay
attention to this is not something that
we can afford to lose
so so i don't want to say this is
pessimistic a lot of people seem to
think that when i talk about escalation
in a conflict it's pessimism and i'm
like
don't don't take it to a dark place it's
realism
right take a look at the story from the
daily mail exclusive
do you want to pay 50 for a hamburger
joe
furious restaurant owners vent at biden
for telling them to raise wages what
they say will lead to more inflation
and drive them all out of business this
story what does it have to do with what
i just said
food costs are the are typically the
number one indicator of when a
revolution happens or some kind of major
revolt
so if joe biden the white house
administration are giving everybody 15
16 bucks an hour not to work
restaurants are shutting down taco bell
food shortage wendy's i think
chicken food is a shortage on chicken
and i think there may be on beef there's
a labor shortage across the board
because of the unemployment food costs
go up
so this guy asked joe biden you know hey
what do we do we can't hire people and
he goes that's your problem pay more
what so think about and we've mentioned
this a lot but think about
if someone's getting 16 bucks an hour to
not work why would they accept
16 bucks an hour to work you're
basically offering them
zero dollars for 40 hours a week
right right and i had a i had a friend
you know um in virginia
my old friend he's where he works as a
bartender and
he comes back to me and we're just
catching up and he's and i'm like
so how's it going at work and he's like
it's great i'm like the only bartender
here i'm getting all the tips
i'm like well that's great for you but
what happened to all the rest of them
they like
and he said well guess what they just
never came back just never came back
and and the owner is completely reliant
upon me to do all the bartending that's
a bad sign
for a restaurant i've been in that
position before the restaurant went out
of business
yeah and that's where we're headed so
what do you where do where does it feel
like this is all going
there are these memes man it is so hard
to live in a functioning society
when you have young idealistic
individuals with
with arrogance but ignorance
so there's this there's this viral uh
tweet that keeps getting reposted by
young people on reddit because
they just don't know what they're
talking about and it's it's like this
tweet goes
so uh so so if we raise the minimum wage
to 15
you're mad that everyone's getting paid
the same as you then
then go to your boss and tell them you
want to raise
or you can go work an easier job for
more money and if you can't figure
that out you need to reassess your
critical thinking skills and i just like
face palm so hard i nearly break my nose
because i'm like first of all whoever
said fast food was an easier job
than working where you were at you know
what i mean the assumption that the
job's gonna be easier no it's probably
worse it's a low-skilled job
but anyway regardless if you go to your
boss and say
hey i can go get that job for 15 bucks
an hour it's easier
give me more money okay then the cost of
goods at your business
goes up to accommodate the rise in labor
costs
now the guy who flips the burgers
realizes that he can't get your service
anymore but it's too expensive
it normalizes regardless of what
artificial numbers you put in place it
won't change anything
other than to drive up inflation
inflation can move very very quickly
in the short term but people's salaries
are much harder to move and the hardest
thing is
rent and that is i think the the the
breaking point for the system
rent why rent is locked
building management is not so let's
think about this way
this guy says you gotta pay me more
otherwise i'm gonna go i'm gonna quit
and so the guy says okay i'll pay you
more let's say that guy is a building
manager
he's the or the soup the superintendent
the guy who makes sure the pipes are
working and repairs things
he's getting paid you know he's in new
york city gets paid 50k whatever he
manages his big building
well now his cheeseburgers cost 30
because they're paying all the
the employees 20 bucks an hour 25 bucks
an hour to accommodate
to to to to beat in competition the
government's free money
so now he goes to he goes to the
building owner and says
if you want me to maintain this building
i need
a massive raise because if these people
are getting 12 bucks an hour now they're
getting 20
i mean that's that's nearly a 50 raise
so he's like i want
75k a year the landlord says
there is no way i can afford to pay you
that
because i don't make that much in rent
from this building
and then he says then i will quit if he
quits
then who maintains the building nobody
will do you think the people who are
there who are
talking about how the rent is too high
are going to be able to pay to fix the
pipes what if the pipe bursts in the
hallway which is a communal space who's
the responsible
who's responsible for it so maybe the
landlord says okay
then i'll have to raise rent yes when
the leases are up
because you can't just go to the
individuals and say hey i'm jacking your
rent up
so that's where there's a hard stop the
building managers
the maintenance the repairs will
immediately need more money
but the landlord can't get it and some
states have rent control i think
california does where you can only raise
the rent like three percent
annually that's right and so what
they'll do is they'll try and get you to
move out
so that they can then re-rent the place
for like 10 time or
twice the cost literally the end result
of this will be
people becoming homeless because either
the landlord says
i'm done with the building i can't
afford to pay it i'm selling it yes and
then it goes
out if they sell it and it goes to
blackrock
to somebody who says we can eat these
costs or
they say everybody get out i don't care
or they say i'll turn it over to you
they become slumlords
unable to afford the the the short-term
inflation hits them
but rent can't change so they can't they
can't make that money up that quickly
i had a place in la that i was renting
and the owner sold it
and then so they gave me notice they're
like you have to move out we sold it so
here we're going to pay you to move out
they paid me like a month two months
rent or something to move out
but i had to move out wasn't anticipated
here's the problem let's say you live in
this building
and the landlord says we're gonna pay
you to move out you go up on craigslist
or whatever
website you use zillow and you notice
all of a sudden like you were paying
you know two thousand dollars a month
for your for your apartment in new york
and you gotta leave all the apartments
now are three grand yeah because any
listed apartment
of course will be raised to accommodate
for maintenance costs
and then right you're out you're
homeless or you move out of the cities
move somewhere cheaper and then probably
encounter the same problem or
maybe you just say i give up give me the
free money from the government
and i'm gonna go live in a van down by
the river yeah and this is so i mean
this is so interesting because
you know everybody talks about oh it's
it's just inflation jobs are going to
increase
but what happens with inflation is
exactly like you say
um the fixed costs that not the fixed
cost the costs that are unable to be
leased up um within a certain period
because of contractual obligations tend
to fold
things tend to go bankrupt and people
get homeless this is how you cause a lot
of
social problem with just a very small
small shift
in in the in the economic atmosphere and
this is like this is what happened with
the great recession right i mean with
the great recession
you had a default rate that rose
somewhat significantly in the home
ownership
uh because people were not able to pay
back their mortgages
and because of that small shift in
mortgage rates there were so many
financiers who were who
bet on low default rates
and they were not able to get the
returns that they want and that caused a
massive
gradated shift across the economy that
eventually resulted in the great
recession so these little things make
big differences
yeah uh i guess long story short
i think uh they're doing it on purpose
you know if
if someone came to me and they laid
these pieces out in front of me and said
take a look at these puzzle pieces what
picture do you see and i'm like
joe biden purposely tanking the economy
to trigger some kind of mass unrest huh
there's you know cause i i was talking
to allison earlier
and i was like after after seeing the
news
about them opening up the border gate
and just letting people walk through
and the covid rates are rising among
them 40 border patrol agents getting
covered
regardless of whether or not there's a
we cause we mentioned 188 000 but how
many people
actually had covet and how they based on
that ratio regardless of that
they're saying without mass vaccination
then we have to lock down
okay but you just let in 188 000 people
and you didn't test them or vaccinate
them
so how are we supposed to increase that
ratio when you're pumping the numbers
back down
i said there is no way the biden
administration is
so dumb that they're seeing that
and simultaneously seeing vaccination
rates and going
oh uh uh this is fine this works no they
like i'm sorry man
i'm not gonna sit here and pretend that
i as some random individual know more
than they do
i i look joe biden we can claim is just
sitting there like a muppet
dumb as a box of rocks and kamala's
doing but he's got a cabinet and
certainly these people are like
oh look at that a million people this
year how are we supposed to track for
that
how are we supposed to avoid lockdowns
and restrictions
if they're just opening the gates and
letting people come through
they have to see that right like they
realize that the
the the paradox and what they're asking
for they unfortunately don't have they
they have to see it they don't have to
understand it or recognize it
come on cognitive dissonance do you
really think that these people in
government are like
i don't understand why this is a problem
i think a lot of the people
are they know full well the federal
reserve is out of control and that the
economy is going to crash
as if it keeps inflating so they're just
hitting the gas and they're like in
behind closed doors they're like
calculating the the losses that we're
going to see a lot of people are going
to be this a lot of people are going to
be that
they're just accepting it behind closed
doors and just like the great depression
telling us everything's fine
i think you're right to go back to what
you were saying about the great
recession kenny with um
you know all the problems it led to i
don't think we've ever escaped the great
recession
i think the titanic hit the iceberg and
it's just a long and slow split
because if you look at the money stock
the m1 money stock
you can actually see that everything's
like very very stable in terms of growth
until 2008 it goes up sharply
and then 2020 it's sky it spikes and
they're like but we
but we changed the way we calculate this
oh that's right
yeah we'll see what happened was because
of covid they said you can now use your
savings accounts
like checking accounts which it put all
of a sudden the savings
money and savings accounts accounts into
the general money supply yeah causing a
massive spike
so it looks i think that's that big
spike we saw is this titanic splitting
and now it's going to go down and ian
you are correct i agree with you
because i think what they're doing i
think they know that's my point they're
watching they know
but they're the people who are trying to
steal as much of much of the fine china
and silverware
before the ship goes down they're
grabbing as much as they can
so imagine being on this boat and then
you hear a big rumble
and you're like what was that and then
you see these super rich people
just frantically carrying silverware and
running full speed towards the lifeboats
and you're just like i wonder why
they're doing that at least we're not
being locked in our rooms with the doors
welded shut
that's fair well to be fair people in
cities technically
stay at home orders all last year now
the threats of more lockdowns regarding
bringing meritocracy into the economy
because like i was saying at the
beginning of the show jordan peterson
mentions
you see it throughout his throughout
culture except in economy because
ultimately wealthy people transfer
wealth to kids that aren't necessarily
intelligent or valuable but they're
super i think that valuable yeah
valuable to society is what i mean
they're more of a drain than a plus but
what i i think we can do
is create a system where everyone can
have their own cryptocurrency i've
talked about this before and then
you can if you want to like subscribe to
my channel for 10 bucks a month cool but
if you want to pay me an ian coin i'll
give you a 10
discount so i generate desire for my
token
and so we've created almost like a
meritocratic economy where there's
all these different currencies and the
the valuable ones are the ones that give
you the most utility
right right maybe yeah yeah i mean i
think
crypto is interesting um there was a
huge crypto revolution
2017 2018. everybody thought all of
their cryptocurrencies were gonna go
and be great but actually pareto rule
only one or two of them
really ended up skyrocketing it was
bitcoin and ethereum yeah but if you
bought dogecoin
back when it came out man you got rich
there's like one dude as a millionaire
now of dogecoin i'm not too worried
about the actual dollar value because
in a system like that there would be no
like central currency that everything is
like
valued at it would just they would all
have value right based on
the individual well this i mean the
reason why we have a single currency
money economy is to to eat to facilitate
transactions just to make it a lot
easier
wouldn't it be easier for the world if
everyone had a one world currency
yeah that sounds like globalization yeah
why wouldn't it happen
look at bitcoin bitcoins used by
everybody around the world it's true
so i don't know if bitcoin will ever be
hard currency but we're certainly moving
towards a future where some crypto will
be
and maybe that's kind of the point maybe
the titanic hit that
2008 when did bitcoin come out ian 2008
2009 2009 right wasn't it yeah yeah so
somebody saw it was like we need we need
i mean look i'm not saying conspiracy
i'm saying the crisis happens
and this satoshi dude or whoever whether
it's a multiple people or not was like
that's a problem we need sound currency
bitcoin boom so now what happens it's
just dominoes falling over man
we start seeing economic crisis economic
collapse the government is full of a
bunch of
benny hill type stooge cops running
around with their holding their hats
frantically trying to figure out what's
going on
and it's all melting down and then in
the end what happens
everybody in the world uses one thing
bitcoin crypto we're positioned now is
the united states where
we have the power it's kind of like
george washington when he was president
he had the power they wanted him to
become a king
do you want the united states to stay
the power but like we have a
responsibility just as washington did to
give that power
away to step down and i think
now we're in the position to create a
world economy that with all these
different types of currencies that
intermingle and enter
intercorrelate yeah you know what man i
i would love
for there to be some kind of
system global system that
defends freedom protects uh sovereign
borders
but still allows us to avoid war and
function in a unified manner in a
certain sense wait hold on
global system that protects freedom
what what kind how could a system which
is by
nature organized and therefore has to
suppress some freedom or to gain
organization
also protect freedom like a bill of
rights uh
a system based around a core of
ideologies that says
in order to violate a person's rights
they're much there must be due process
so we have organized a system in the us
not perfect but pretty good now there's
a lot of places in the world that don't
have that
i'm not suggesting we go with force and
kick their doors in and then staple
constitutions to their walls
but it would be awesome if whatever ends
up happening with mass communications
we don't end up with a chinese communist
style overarching global authority
we end up with a classically liberal we
respect if you live in the united states
then you are allowed to set the laws of
the united states however no war
international agreements on not having
war not stealing resources
you know there's got to be something um
i'll tell you this
there's that famous quote that uh i
think it was um for
one of the rothschilds i'm not entirely
sure you would probably know where he
said
that it's not it's not uh it's not that
uh
what do you say globalization will
happen whether anybody wants it to or
not or something like that
and a lot of people i know a lot of
libertarians and caps think he was
you know twirling his mustache going
globalization what happened
when in reality he was saying like the
way the world is going with
communications and trade
we will eventually have a one world
government the the goal i suppose is
the united states and those who live in
it should be able to have their rights
respected within their own borders
they should have their constitutional
freedoms and rights they shouldn't be
banned or censored or shut down
but there could be an international
agreements on
what happens in the event of conflict of
war of territorial disputes
so we can get to that point we can't
have a system we already do have a
system by which we have an international
currency it's called visa and mastercard
i can go to any country in the world my
car and swipe and buy what i want it's
so easy the swift payment system
that's the global swift payment system
because i'll tell you man i've been
watching a lot of stargate sg-1
and you know one of the biggest problems
is that was and i'm not talking about
the fiction of the show i'm talking
about the writers perceive when they're
making the show
right is that when they encounter other
worlds and try to negotiate they say you
can't negotiate on the behalf of your
people
you like if we give you weapons or
utility you'll go to war and you'll
destroy yourselves
so we need to have some kind of we need
to we need to have a way to prevent
world war three or whatever now of
course there are powerful global
interests elites who desperately want
a one world authority the only problem
is they're crackpot authoritarians who
would burn your life to the ground
and suck and they don't they don't they
don't care about you as an individual
they care about the numbers the
utilitarianism
that's a nightmarish world deliver
that's what the chinese communist party
does
so i'm saying we don't want that okay
but let me give you a
different perspective you know our
founding fathers were authoritarians
because we're authoritarians well this
here this is what i mean
i mean that we gave them authoritarian
power to write our
constitution like at one point
in time in the us history we had an
authoritarian government
because those people were the ones who
eventually came together and then
they created the constitutional system
that now protects freedom but in order
to do that we had to trust them with the
ability to
to make a constitution and a bill of
rights and then to actually execute on
that at least for the first time but
they didn't just
take they just write a constitution and
staple it to a wall and say this is what
you have to deal with
it was actually extremely difficult in
order to actually get the constitution
they were going to states and
negotiating in the states were like
bug off we don't care we don't want this
and it was actually very very difficult
and took i think over like 15 or 20
years
to finally get states to actually vote
for and sign on to the constitutional
system
it did it did but we still trusted them
to make
the to make the initial creative effort
now we had the ability to to provide a
backlash against that but again you know
we had
george washington could have been king
he could have been a president
so he had to have the he had to actually
step down and say okay i'm not actually
going to do that
other people you know that just shows we
didn't have the authoritarian
rule right and and that system was still
being developed at that time
and there were people who exercised sort
of authoritarian influence like in
marbury versus madison judicial branch
was not granted the ability for judicial
review at the time
they gave themselves the ability for
judicial review and marbury versus
madison so they kind of had a little bit
of a
we're going to get some power nobody
gave them the ability to do that but
they did
so but is that is that is that is are
some instances of of authority being
exercised in bad ways
indicative of the entire system being
authoritarian at some point
i would say yes you have totalitarian
authoritarians which are
very dangerous where like the author of
the the constitution is the
authoritarian i mean it's the exact same
word
authoritarian yeah that's the root of
the word authoritarian author
and they're right is a system
defined by an authority that can that
commands on down
versus liberty a liberty based system a
weaker centralized power structure i
think there's never
uh it's never all or none you always
have aspects of authority
within any given system right a family
unit a government
democratic if you go all the way to the
top of the political compass to
authoritarian
you've got a guy who's beating the
peasants to death and
holding people at gunpoint to steal
their stuff authoritarian if you go
that's that's that's the epitome of
authoritarian if you go all the way to
the bottom you get anarchy
and it's where either you have free
trade anarchy where it's you know and
caps or you have
anarcho-syndicalism or communism where
people are sitting around and
basking in the glories of their labor
which is utopian to be complicated it's
like a lack of authority
or a tribe these these wait right
anarchy means without authority
so if you go all the way to the bottom
with anarchy you can literally have
a small tribe of people who agree to
share things and don't really ever think
about money
or you can have free market capitalists
that are just like hey the market
dictates
so just because somebody says i should
have the ability to like you know
there's somebody who says i'm writing
this constitution and this is what i
think we should do doesn't mean the
system is authoritarian
they're like so we can either uh
it's it's it's it's a gradient okay you
could be 60
libertarian with 40 authoritarian you
can be you know any any any number well
you know what thomas hobbes says about
that
what does he say i mean he says he says
the function of a government is to hold
people at gunpoint they have the
the function of government has the power
to hold somebody at gunpoint and demand
things from them
you know that he said even basically
even we have this he would say you know
we have this veneer of liberalism right
now where we give the people the
illusion the ability that they have you
know
rights and sincere voting power but
really you know
who has the ability to coerce you it's
the government yeah
it's it's it's true but so in that sense
it's just
just because there are rules doesn't
mean we're an authoritarian government
because
the one thing about the united states is
and this is a lesson conservative should
have learned a while ago
you're allowed to speak for the most
part and
use that ability to build culture now
there are confines in the overton window
but because many people on the right
weren't actively building culture
they were chasing after it constantly
defending from what the left wanted
the left owns the narrative in the
united states we
we have an authoritarian culture that is
taking over we still have some
libertarian aspects within it
and if we don't stop the authoritarian
encroachment it goes into government
which it is with what joe biden is doing
and this this this is something i was
talking about four or five years ago
and and now here we are where we're
dangerously close
to the government absorbing
authoritarian cultural aspects
and the people who oppose it being too
fractured to do anything about it
what i mean to say is for the longest
time the united states was not
authoritarian in that
you could absolutely have your you know
crackpot free speech group going around
saying crazy things
and even have the aclu defend you as you
march through skokie illinois
with saying saying horribly and
anti-semitic things but that was because
we authoritatively decided you could do
that by saying if you're gonna stop them
from doing that we're gonna
keep we're gonna arrest you so they have
freedom that's a thought that's the
authoritarian aspect of argument
you misunderstand what authoritarian
means you think right
yeah a cop who says i can't arrest a guy
for speaking is an authoritarian
a guy a cop who says i can arrest you if
you try to physically harm that person
is still not an authoritarian oh i think
they are authoritarian i mean police by
nature are authoritarian
they are the author of law yeah they're
at least the arm of the author they're
an authority
i think you misunderstand authoritarian
which is a government system
of a top-down authority in centralized i
would i would argue that
saying that a government saying the big
a authoritarian is a misnomer that you
really can't
say again you're just using you're
always guardian it's always a gradient
of authority within a government so
you're confusing the word authority with
authoritarian
so so the police are constrained by the
public in many many ways now the cops
cops can do bad things
they can they can seize your guns and
smart with a smile on their face when
they do it they will kick grandma and
the teeth to enforce these
lockdowns so we're entering that period
that's what i'm saying we are entering
an authoritarian government because the
it starts with the culture
and moves in and nothing was understood
but in the city however oh we had civil
rights where they and they won
they integrated the schools with
authoritarianism they went in
with guns in their arms and said we're
now this this school is now integrated
but that wasn't because a king or a a
centralized command structure made it so
it was the
president it was yes and it was because
of mandate from the public
true yeah we are our own author in that
system so you're confusing authoritarian
well maybe maybe it's the totalitarian
which is the extreme authoritarianism
is actually totalitarianism if you've
got a house with 10 people in it
and six people demand pepperoni you know
on their pizza and four demand
uh pineapple
is it authoritarian when the six people
are like were ordering pepperoni
no it's it's it's a democratic vote now
democracy can be tyranny tyranny
of the majority but there's a big
difference between a centralized
hierarchical command structure of
authority
that dictates everyone has to do
something and no one can do anything
about it and a group of people coming
out voicing their opinion and the system
changing in response
to the world people when you have one
person issuing the authority it's very
dangerous but when you have a group
able to do it it's called democracy so
so to to clarify too
there can be cult authoritarianism for
sure everybody marching to dogma
and just reacting in a certain way and
that's
black lives matter and and and critical
race theory and critical race applied
principles
but when that goes into government you
end up with dictatorial presidents
screaming the top of their lungs
threatening people and using those
powers against their perceived enemies
and that's when your government becomes
authoritarian
okay it's interesting let's i want to go
back to your pizza example for a second
i think it's interesting so the group
decides
so six people they're ten people six
people designed pepperoni
four people decide on pineapple but
someone still has to make the call to
dominoes and say okay we're getting
pepperoni pizza yup
now that person may say i have the
mandate to call
domino's uh because
we have the majority who said they want
pepperoni so i'm gonna call pepperoni
but what if somebody on the pineapple
side was like
well no you don't have the mandate
because we want to make it unanimous
you're like well no i think it's
majority rule and at that point it's a
it's actually
i could see it be the person who
is who calls the pepperoni is just
actually just
asserting his power over 10 people did
you agree to the rules
i don't know did they yes i mean we've
long had a structure in place of like
here's how we'll have the vote
here here good certainly shake hands
these are the rules for the game in
terms of how we make decisions
then four people start screaming it's
not fair it's not fair it's what you get
with 2016.
they all agreed to the rules of the
election and then screamed all these
horrible things about about you know
donald trump when it came to the 2020
election a bunch of republicans and
democrats started changing voter rules
in many states
which resulted in a major lawsuit by
texas which is very very different which
is i can understand why many of the
trump supporters are angry about it
among other things
so the issue is if you and i agree we're
going to arm wrestle and the winner gets
to choose what topping we put on our
pizza and you lose you can't then claim
well you you don't have the mandate
that's authoritarian i'm like bro we
agree to this
right we agreed to a sorting mechanism
by which we decide how things are made
just because we have to make hard
decisions and someone has to be the one
to do it
doesn't mean that it's an authoritarian
system if if if black lives matter
gains power because of their cult
ideology they will have the ability to
enforce this because they have a bunch
of zealots who go around smashing
windows and beating people
but there will be one person who
exercises the authority
and dictates to their cult to go and
take action
then the will of the people doesn't
matter anymore so you look at cuba
most people did not want communism they
did not want a dictatorship
but they were tricked and manipulated
and the revolutionary forces of castro
had the ability to take whatever they
wanted
people resisted there was no agreement
to that that was authoritarian
manny no one voted for him to do this
well actually i don't know exactly if
maybe they had a faux vote but i'm
pretty sure the elections never came
that's what jose was saying
the constitution never came the election
never came and before we knew it
castro was just the dictator who
controlled everything that's where we're
going
thanks to critical race theory and the
elimination of meritocracy the idea is
get you cut off the tall grass you take
away anyone's ability to challenge you
and you mandate things based on
seemingly random characteristics
and then that's another way that's
probably the the one of the surefire
ways towards authoritarianism
with a meritocratic system you it's it's
not as easy to have authoritarianism but
you can
right with america system you can get
let's
let's just call it a a free market
system over time monopolies form power
develops and you get the east india
trading company no regulation the
wealthiest most powerful company that
ever existed
and they can do what they want set up
cities enslave people attack people
with central centralization with leftist
ideology with things like critical race
theory
you use ideology and you just centralize
authority
immediately so instead of taking a long
amount of time to earn your position
they assert it by force right i mean
this is this is the premise of my book
you know an inconvenient minority so you
know critical race theorists
you know they they actually
it's funny the way we talk about
critical race there is because you need
to realize that critical race theorists
use race as a marketing tool they use
race as a marketing tool to get people
of that race
to support them to value them to buy
their books to vote for them
everything like that race is a marketing
tool that that's
at this at this stage of of things um
it was it's a marketing tool for for the
purpose
of of eventual oppression because if you
can convince somebody
that their race is what matters to you
and race is a set of characteristics
that involves
not acting white or acting white or this
kind of thing then you can convince them
to do things
based on things that they wouldn't
otherwise have chosen to do because
you've appealed to
a racial identity well there's another
component to the critical race theory
stuff yeah and it's it's the riots
that's their physical enforcement if you
don't agree with them
they smash your window so what do we see
in places like berkeley
people in their windows they put up
black lives matter signs the signs don't
actually mean they support black lives
matter the signs actually mean please
don't hurt me
yeah i think i think that kenny is
making the extremely salient point that
at the end of the day
the bottom line is the question of who
decides
and this is the issue of censorship who
decides what is misinformation who
decides whether joe biden should be
taken off youtube
and joe biden mentioned this a little
while ago he's like it's not so much
about the votes as who counts the votes
that is the person who decides who's
going to be in power
the person who calls the shots let's
let's let's let we'll uh we'll let's
talk about critical race there in these
schools kenny where where are you from
uh i'm from uh virginia were you born in
virginia i was born in maryland i moved
to virginia
when i was three years old born in
maryland
so you're an american and you just
happen to be of uh
asian descent you you've uh of asian
ethnicity your parents are asian but you
are an american citizen
right what i see in this and what the
schools are doing like harvard to
to asian americans to people of asian
descent is they're simply saying because
you look like
those people you can't go to this school
that's that's it
yeah they're treating you based on
something that you can't control about
yourself they're also treating you based
on something you didn't consent to give
them
you know uh harvard asked for asks for
race
uh in your college application but even
if you don't give your race
don't they're still going to find out
what race you are because they have an
access to a database of all the students
in the entire country
and they know not just your race they
know
your they know your family's household
income
they know you're the neighborhood that
you live in they know the school that
you went to they know the crime rate of
the school that they went to
and so regardless of how you consent to
this if you consent to give
this information or not they're going to
treat you based on it you know and this
is the new
this is the marriage harvard's
admissions process
is the marriage of racial profiling with
data mining
that's what it is it is it it represents
an authoritarian future
yeah no no it represents an
authoritarian future
where people um are going to
get information from you without your
consent and
things like race background everything
like that and then judge you on it
that that is what the authoritarians
will eventually do it and harvard's
process is an example of
where we're going as a culture the main
thing i see here that is that is
the most alarming is as we mentioned
earlier in the show the left doesn't
view individuals they don't see
individuals
their whole system is comprised of
utility that's it that's why they're
like
how many asians are in the school too
many how many white people too many how
many latinos not enough how many black
people not enough
they don't care about the individuals
and the work being done and they don't
care about the fact that
there could quite literally be a black
man who was born in spain
and he's hispanic he speaks spanish and
so they're like ah but his skin looks a
certain way
and then you have american americans in
this country
who are of any background and they're
like we want you to go to the school
simply because of how you look what the
how what does that matter it doesn't
matter at all
i can't believe there were a point where
they're simply saying we want people to
look different
it's interesting it's it's an
interesting conversation because
genetically obviously we're different
everyone's different and probably
because of our ancestry
there's subtle differences in our
genetics that are interesting to talk
about
um i i just
oh god i had another part of that point
that i did well the the point is
regardless of certain things like i went
to uh
thailand and i was taller than everybody
right
i certainly think through hard work and
dedication and commitment
and uh you can achieve great things and
become the best of the best of the best
now of course there's there's always
going to be a michael phelps he's got
a wider arm span than normal and if
someone was saying like
he produces less lactate uh what is it a
lactic acid or something
yeah so this makes him just the best
swimmer ever yeah well you know
that happens and that's kind of why we
have competition but
most people can earn experience and
skills
and work hard and be dedicated and make
themselves better in a variety of ways
maybe you're not the smartest you could
be the strongest maybe you're not the
tallest you can be you can be super fast
you can work really hard mugsy bows man
that guy could 360 dunk that dude
could jump so high it doesn't matter in
my opinion what you look like
it matters if you have this the
determination the the the commitment
the willingness to do better to be
better and so what the problem i have
with all of this is first and foremost
how insane is it that these people would
look at a a 10 ten-year-old vietnamese
kid whose parents came here from from
vietnam and they say oh honey you can't
go to harvard
you look like those people too much
that's it
for the only reason you will never go to
this ivy league school
you look like those that that's insane
to me yes people are scumbags
well you know i agree with you there
look um and i'll just show you some
facts look
harvard university um you have to score
if you're an asian american you have to
score 440 points higher on the s.a.t to
have the same chance of admission
as a black american wow yeah simply
because you both have different color
skins
simply because you bought the different
colors out of 1600 points if you
submitted
the out of 1600 if you no actually that
was out of 2400
back in the old 2400 days if you
submitted
an application the exact same
application
and you had the same sat score the same
grades the same objective metrics you
the only thing you did was you changed
your race from
asian to black a harvard admissions
officer is going to look at the asian
application and they're going to say
uh he's just like all the other asians
she's probably groomed by his parents
over achieving
test taking nerd no personality you
change it to black the story is most
likely going to be
oh my gosh this guy is the greatest
thing since sliced bread we have to
admit him and give him everything
yeah when i was at yeah and it's not and
the thing is
the thing is they they say they do this
to
admit the you know kids from
underprivileged backgrounds but if you
look at the
even the black admits at harvard
university
70 70 plus percent of them are upper
middle class or higher and 50 percent of
them
are immigrants or children of black
immigrants so they're not even admitting
the kid
from the south side of chicago you know
who
you may think deserves or should get
that chance they're admitting
the privileged kid who looks black yep
what what a disgusting uh reality i
suppose when i when i was growing up i
was told
never to let anyone know that i was
asian if i was applying for a job
i would have to lie i started putting
other on my things like
10 years ago or 15 years ago it's just
so gross i remember i was applying for a
job
and i was told oh just just don't put
asian put mexican or something else i
was like why
and i was told asians don't have
powerful special interest groups
so they don't get special favors in
government and people are allowed to
discriminate against you on the basis of
your race if you tell them that you tell
them the truth about you know your
family
is it was it or do you say lydia doesn't
it strike you as unbelievably racist for
them to look at a black applicant and be
like
holy cow this person is insanely special
do you remember what joe biden said
about obama yes sir
geez he said
it he said the first articulator yeah
he's so articulated such an articulate
gentleman yeah and i was like what
like i think they call it race realism
when you talk about the actual
genetic differences of and i don't even
think it's different races am i right to
say that like the human
well race realists believe in like hard
racial differences right and which i
mean according to genetics i think there
are there's a reason why skin colors
come out differently they take it into a
very
s like that's the problem with it
because it's a fascinating conversation
just to know
but that doesn't mean that we're
different like that we have different um
senses of freedom we're all equally
valuable and able
of course yes and i think one of the
problems with race realism is that
people look a lot of people make
assumptions it's how humans work
we look at something we say here's why i
think i think this is why it's happening
let me test that
and then race realists think if i see
you know something like the bell curve
uh and i see these differences based on
iq it it clearly
must be the racial component and perhaps
some of it you know i think it was sam
harris and a few other i think i'm not
sure who was sam harris and maybe some
of the idw people saying
there's some component there obviously
why wouldn't there be but
they think it's the end-all be-all
absolute reason and i think that is
likely incorrect i do think there's a
mix between nature and nurture for sure
but i think human potential is is
typically not met and that means
regardless of your race if you study
hard and you work hard you can be the
best of the best of the best
you might not be like the number one
position but you might
but you might it's just it's just it's
just there's eight billion people you
know
it's one in eight billion to be number
one who knows who that's going to be or
why
i think part of what kenny is seeing and
part of what you see with these
black kids being like the kids of
nigerian immigrants
is a cultural thing so tim's talking
about how that you
look a certain way so that means you're
not going to have a chance to get in do
you think it is how you look or do you
think it's at least
partly because of the asian cultural
preference
for hard work and studying and all that
so you know this is a complicated
question i'm not a race realist
i i think that predominantly what
explains
uh disparities in i think predominantly
what
would uh predicates disparities in the
united states with regards to a lot of
these things is cultural
i think that cultural factors uh for
example asian americans don't come to
the us with like a significantly higher
iq
than the average person and in fact
studies have shown that asians with
lower iq are able to overcome that lower
iq
because they study pretty hard they work
really hard
and they're actually able to compete
with whites at an iq bracket it's a
quintile higher a quintile
standard deviation higher than them so
this is this is this is this is massive
this is
this shows you that it's not just your
iq
that makes you successful you really
have to put in the work and what asian
americans do
on average and i'm saying this on
average every individual is different
there are a lot of
asian americans who don't work hard but
asian americans individually on
average study twice as many hours as the
average american per week
it's wow well i'll tell you this i think
it's cultural it is
like you guys i i was i was i was
tutored by my mom when i was
like one or two and she's she's korean
what is she 100
korean like born in korea half korean no
born in the united states
okay her parents were one of her parents
was from korea yep
born in korea i don't know exactly where
but
my grandmother was 100 korean and that
trickles down a little bit i suppose i
would imagine i mean i
value free speech because i'm an
american because i was born here and
raised here with these cultural values
if i have children i'm going to pass
those on to my children it's not because
of the way i look
but the people that are my progeny or
look like me then you will but but
it's not even about that you believe in
free speech yes and your parents came
from china
there you go the chinese communist party
does not believe in free speech
if people can be whatever you know what
i mean that's why
you know uh there was a story that came
out recently gallup poll
race relations are worse than they've
been in like a really long time
and i think it's because millennials are
extremely racist i think that
modern leftist and progressive
millennials are the most
racist we've seen in a very very very
long time
and so that's why you see around like
2013 race relations plummet
because this is when millennials start
aging into the workforce
into influential positions and they
start espousing their racist ideology
now you have racist millennials admitted
white supremacists like robin d'angelo
espousing racist ideals
and then all of a sudden you've got a
bunch of minorities being like oh these
people are racist
what when alma really did lay on that
race card
during occupy wall street when the
occupy activists
segregated all the activists by race i
remember seeing
yeah no joke they did crazy they created
race-based caucuses for voting on how
the how
the body would spend money let me talk
to the media it was crazy
they literally they literally but they
literally had like the hispanic caucus
the asian caucus the people of color
caucus the black caucus
and so i remember they split up all the
groups based on race and there was this
black dude chilling because
zuccari park where occupy happens is
slightly downhill so there's like this
ledge that slowly turns into a very
highlight it's like very small
at the top of the by the street and then
as you walk down the ground goes down
the ledge stays the same height and he's
sitting up on top of it i see him
arguing with somebody
and i walk over and i'm listening to him
and he just goes do you have any idea
what the press is going to say when they
find out y'all segregated based on race
and i started laughing and i'm like dude
yes like these people have lost it but
you know what their ideology is winning
that's crazy because it's so it has
the the the question of success in
america has
much less to do with your race
your race than it has to do with these
cultural values that can be adopted
by any race and to say uh i mean
you know hard work studying hard any
race can do it doesn't matter if you're
asian they call that you can study hard
if you're white
that was that that was did you know that
yeah do you see that thing you're black
did you see that that graphic they had
on the was the african-american
history museum whatever yeah and it said
like working hard having a schedule was
whiteness
that to me is absolutely insane but i
will add
yeah there have been several studies
done and they found
one trait that guarantees success or i
should say
one trait that was was highly correlated
with success
iq right no no what is it is it well is
that a trait
it yes it isn't wealth it is an iq it
isn't race
it isn't uh national origin it isn't
gender
it's perseverance mm-hmm great that's
for sure one thing they found
among every group every race every
gender every age bracket every iq
bracket
every class was those who refused to
give up succeeded and those who gave up
failed
yep that's incredible i mean yeah this
is one exam this is one reason why black
americans who
join the military who join the army
actually tend to have much
higher career success outcomes both
military and
non-military afterwards um you know in
the army you're taught things like
perseverance you're taught things like
overcoming and resilience and everything
like that and the people who are put
with that kind of structure in their
lives
you know can can really elevate and
that's why you see black americans who
are
in the military you know are
disproportionately well represented
among the upper middle and
and upper classes in america when you
were um
studying the uh the meritocracy and the
failure of is it harvard is it harvard
that's doing these admissions things
was that we said it's okay so here's the
thing about
this this crazy thing that's happening
in harvard all of this this admissions
process this race
baiting and and profiling started at
harvard but it has since
it has since grown to become an entire
ivy league phenomenon
and then from there the ivy league
exported this ideology to big
corporations like google and facebook
and now you see google and facebook and
their diversity and inclusion programs
also be anti-asian you know i just
published this article in colette
magazine
asians make up 90 of silicon valley's
software engineers wow
90 of silicon valley software engineers
but you go up
each level of management
asians get lower and lower and lower
percentage until
in the executive level they're only like
20 of the executive level of facebook
and google
and um you know this this is an example
of
and and nobody is advocating for asians
to be hired more or promoted more in
silicon valley and things like that
because they don't fit the narrative
because they're still considered
overrepresented
meritocracy man yeah have you found the
if you earn it if you can do it
then there you go like if you were you
able to isolate methodologies that
enhance meritocracy amongst education
and business
so i think that one of the things that
you have to so first of all
um you know i understand iq is
is correlated significantly with with
performance in college and
particularly not just iq but
standardized test scores
you have to look at objective metrics
like standardized test scores
um that people love to rip on tests they
love to rip on standardized tests i get
it it's a lot of work you have to study
but the standardized test measures two
things that are meritorious it measures
your innate intelligence and it measures
how hard you prepare
right because you have to prepare for
tests and if you don't study for tests
you're lazy
and if you're lazy you're not going to
do well in school right so
now harvard is trying to get rid of
standardized tests of admissions
um why they say you know it
disproportionately
uh benefits the wealthy and privileged
over you know poor black and latino
students you know they point to the fact
that blacks tend to do worse
on standardized tests than than other
people but what they conveniently leave
out
is that standardized tests actually
correct
for wealth and privilege because if
you're a
poor kid and an immigrant kid who has no
social connections
you're not you're not going to be able
to stand out
um except to you're not going to be able
to stand out when compared next to a
rich and wealthy kid
except through the standardized test
right right you know this is the
standardized test is the only test that
allows you to be able to compete
side by side with a wealthy and
privileged kid and beat them
because typically what happens is the
guy shows up talks to the dean and says
my son would like to go here let me give
a donation to the west wing
soccer team you're funded lacrosse team
you're funded it gets in
and nearly 10 of harvard's
new class could be considered a children
of a donor a child of a donor
that make this dean's list that harvard
uses to signify
primarily children of donors and 35
of them are legacies what's that what's
a legacy a legacy is a is a kid whose
parents
went to harvard yep yeah so there's a
lot of issues and
uh um i don't know if we have all the
answers but we do have super chats so
let's
let's talk to you guys see what you have
to say if you haven't already smash that
like button subscribe to this channel go
to timcast.com help support our fearless
and independent journalism
and by becoming a member you get access
to exclusive members only segments of
the tim cast irl podcast as well
as an ad free experience all right let's
see we got here mr 36 says hey tim and
crew thank you for all the important
work you do
congratulations on all your success i
can't see wait to see what the future
holds at tim cast much love
from locked down australia good luck
sorry to hear it but um
we got some dungeon masters coming in i
guess the exciting thing is when new
people come they bring an unexpected
like a whole new reality of being
that like changes you know in ways you
didn't even
conceptualize could happen like when
when scott showed up with that diseased
mangy
cat i ran but i couldn't run fast enough
and then ian was like why'd you hire
this guy and i was like get him scott
and then scott
released the cat at ian and i'm kidding
there's no scott scott doesn't exist and
there was no
disease-managing cat no never happened
no
i woke up in the dark and i was like
what's cutting me
[Laughter]
i'm just kidding about that it's very
exciting around here that's non-stop
action we're encouraging people to work
here this is great
all right let's see placid saint says
tim lucas and isaac botkin from t-rex
arm said in an armory livestream on
twitch
they would go on your show by invite
only to talk about changing the culture
on two-way and how to do it
we will take a look into that it would
be fun to talk about guns
because joe biden was basically like
we're gonna man all the guns and it's
like oh he
basically said it seven misoon says ian
looks like a younger version of the
crazy long-haired doctor from
independence day
does he oh oh wait that was brett spiner
wasn't it brent spiner yeah it was yeah
thank you
but you know what was funny like in the
original independence day he's just the
doctor
and then they like really emphasized his
gay marriage in the uh
in the new in the sequel silly you know
i didn't know they like made it
a big component yeah and woke maybe
like my thing is like if it's if it's
emphasized to the same degree as any
marriage would be i really don't care
yeah
but if they make it like a centerpiece
i'm kind of like i get it guys like
the love story is cool but if it's uh
that it's gay
then that's annoying yeah i don't like
that i don't care what gender all right
geno fast says who feeds the chickens
every morning at the tim cast homestead
also hi ian
uh so here's what happens we have a big
uh just it's a gravity feeder it's like
it's a big thing you fill with food
and then as the chickens eat it just
goes down it's great you know they they
scratch and they drag
however chickens eat bugs so really what
happens is
i get up in the morning you know i get
ready after i record the first jo i go
out and i release the chickens to the
farm
and they've decimated the zucchinis and
the tomatoes they're tearing the whole
place to shreds they're little dinosaurs
running around just destroying
everything they're exciting
and we're gonna lay concrete down and
move the garden so it's time for the
chickens to come and destroy it
but there's no feeding them really they
have a feeder
and then they eat bugs and so that's
what they do they go out they eat bugs
and eat vegetables i got a fantastic 10
second video of them on my instagram
page of them just lounging
end of the day chilling out and the
rooster screams so if you want to hear
that rooster go check it out yeah the
dirt baths are funny yeah they like dig
little holes and then like
they're rolling around yeah they're
they're trying to have babies uh
so we i actually found out a couple of
the eggs were fertilized so i'm going to
leave them
and see if they have uh some children
cool some
and they'll be goofy looking i guess
because we got a bunch of different
breeds of chicken you know
mutt chickens that's what i'm talking
about yeah oh yeah
all right let's see what we got jmx says
asian history is very respectable
honorable pragmatic and ancient
the first goal of the ccp was to destroy
that history
one was it the first goal i know it was
a major goal but yeah major goal yeah
erase the the past
that's crazy i just saw the movie hero
you know yeah i watched that yeah who
who mentioned someone mentioned that
andreas i think was talking about it
someone on the show was like hero
because he basically is like
he's an anti-imperial but then by the
end he decides to spare the emperor or
whatever
either way fun movie andreas was saying
it was imperialist propaganda
it was imperialist propaganda yeah
propaganda we didn't know at the time
and now it's
in china is that yeah it's not ccp
propaganda they would ban it if it was
who knows
yeah it's all about control i don't
think they want you to believe any one
thing in particular they just want to
control what you think
and i'm not saying the ccp but
authoritarians in general oh this is fun
rocky says tim and crew you should have
a glossary for your commonly used ideas
with sources on your website
not just overton window but quote there
are four lights that's a good idea
that that would be an interesting thing
to make we keep adding to it yeah just
like
common things we mentioned a little wiki
yeah yeah
john hutto says do we know the 188k
crossing the border are even being all
tested or what percentage were tested no
we don't
no they just walk through the border get
in the car and then drive off
it's amazing isn't it it's a good time
to be a migrant
okay what is this frank says i want to
hear ian say
just like the pied piper led rats to the
streets we dance like marionettes
swaying to the symphony of destruction
just like the pied piper led the rats
through the streets we dance like
marionettes to the symphony of
destruction swaying to the symphony
don't over achieve that's my goal really
close
all right let's see all right
let's uh um oh oh here's a very
important one from make 1984 fiction
again
he says oh he added some to it oh he's
trying to get me
because biden said trinidad shabbat
pressure he says
the pressure pressure yeah the pressure
no there you go
extracellular oh is it not a dondon
there yeah yeah donda de pressure
shabana down to pressure there you go
important
okay let's see where we at
um velvet sphincter says tim please make
your bonus segments an hour long
i would love to however there is one
very difficult challenge there
and that is i already record four hours
a day
of podcasts what's another half an hour
yeah yeah yeah four hours man okay
mental slave says ryan chapman's video
called the marxism behind leftist
identity politics explained
is very well done and informative i
recommend it very interesting
handyman says ian's silver lining
woke-ism will eventually destroy the fed
like it does everything else
it will well i don't know let's
deconstruct the fed rather than
squared says tim look up the etymology
anti the original greek root has
multiple meanings
against and in place of so anti-racism
is a replacement for racism not
something that is against racism
colloquially the modern version of ante
is meant to imply
opposite of or opposed to but that's not
what it means is it it's just a dog
whistle it's a manipulation that's
pretty clever
yep omg puppy says
b.a.p says it's the billionaire
plutocrats versus middle class workers
farmers and small business
they covet their aggregated wealth will
take their property arms and freedom
plutocrats gather power by in inventing
and allying
with fake victim classes that's where
we're headed
wrath of paul says i live in new york
and if mass mandates and or lockdowns
return i will not comply
civil disobedience is our best tool to
fight the covet 1984 regime there are
many people who share the sentiment even
here
in fact i'm not even convinced the
lockdowns can't come back to be to be
completely honest in
uh we already saw one story where i
think it was in victoria they were like
chaos as people just went and did
whatever they wanted
oh i think i yeah new york i i just
think regular people are like i don't
know
how i feel yeah but we're on the middle
of nowhere it's 15. it's very different
here the spread
the whole shut down things is what's
weirds me out because it was
it was just to slow the spread so we
didn't overload the hospitals so now
i don't i don't understand yeah i don't
see why
there's this um i forgot what it's
called you guys do you know about that
that drowning rat experiment
no no no tell me um what is it called
guys in the chat you guys are gonna know
what it's called it was where the guy
put the rats in the tubes and they were
drowning
so uh it took to the sea i think let me
see if i can see
yeah the something rad experiment
experience but uh so here's what
happened
there are these big cylinders full of
water and he would put rats in them
and within 15 minutes the rats would be
struggling and then just give up and
then sink and drown
the whole experiment no it's this it's
the it's a rat experiment yeah that's
what that's what they're calling it
the hope well it it it's not called the
hope experience
there's a name there's a guy who did it
and he has a name
and they do say it's it's an experiment
you know that it shows you the power of
hope which is a creepy story because
here's what happened
the rats would drown in about 15 minutes
with the next screw
he puts the rats in and then right
before they give up and drown he takes
them out
dries them off lets them rest for a few
minutes and then puts them back in
the second time they swam for like
several days
whoa and what they say is it's because
the rats were holding out hoping that
the hand would come back and save them
from their fate
kurt richter kurt richter that's it it's
the kirk richter rat experiment there
you go
that's creepy powerful wow yup wow so
anyway
i bring that up because they're they're
uh people have been mentioning the
similarities
in that or not the similarities but the
idea we get this lockdown it's 15 days
everybody starts boiling in their seats
we get riots and people are losing their
minds and then they lift it all oh
and everyone's like now if the lockdowns
come back they could be indefinite
and people would would sustain
themselves more without becoming
hopeless because
they know if they just hold out there
will be a
end to the lockdown so now assuming this
experiment
translates to humans maybe it doesn't
rats are different
they could lock down for for a decade
wow
hey i'm in the middle of nowhere that's
why i got out of the cities and you got
jack bosovic saying it
you got me saying it we had a travis
corker around with the book escape the
city although he was saying it's not
time to leave the city just yet
my thing is like dude we just got these
electric bikes we're like riding them
around
like in the in you know it's like just
it's a big yard it's like you know
and so we just ride them around we go
skating we've got ramps we got a
barbecue grill
we got chickens the chickens are yelling
you know
it's fun i'd love to build giant tubes
that we could ride up into
and like ride on the sides and like go
around
yes yeah wood prices are going down a
little bit
we got construction on the new studio
happening out here
in the middle of nowhere it's almost
like there's no
restrictions or lockdowns and there
never were to be honest thank god we're
connected to the internet so that i know
what the heck's going on
i mean is that a good thing definitely
sometimes don't you just want to just go
to top of the mountain and just sit back
and look at the stars and yeah
you know pull out a bag of chips and
just you know read a book or something
yes
yeah yeah we're too hyper-connected
these days right there's this it's not
all good
all right dave franco jr says joe biden
is telling the truth the maga movement
is a threat to the power structures that
have exalted these lesser men above us
so it so it is the greatest threat to
his vision of america
not actual regular americans and and
perhaps when joe biden said
the greatest threat since the civil war
he's not talking about the republicans
or the trump supporters
i'm sorry i'm sorry he's not talking
about the greatest threat to america
he's specifically talking to the
oligarchical elites
we we envision him talking to the
american people most of the democrats
he's not even talking to them he's
looking into the eyes of the goldman
sachs banker
saying what they're doing is the biggest
threat since the civil war
right yeah i mean it's it's it's true
because you know in a sense he he does
talk to them in that way because you
know you have
these big huge billionaires mackenzie
bezos and
you know and and bill gates and
everything like that and they're giving
away all of this money and you see how
much money they're giving to all of
these woke
causes yeah you know and how did they
get this idea i mean you would presume
they're smart people
you know if they built all these
companies why are they giving it all to
these things well they're appealing to
their sense um their emotion of
of empathy oh you need to go and
contribute to these people because it
shows that you care because
you can virtue signal so as a result
this is this entire emotion breeding
industry you know results in
billions of dollars for black lives
matter and the like yup
all right james gross says long time
listener first time super chat you've
kept me sane and informed for years
and i look forward to all your future
projects rock on you bald [ __ ] and crew
and larry elder for california governor
larry elder is leading the polls i saw
that
that is the coolest thing i've ever
heard wow but they weren't talking about
it
wasn't it like they showed the top
people he wasn't even on the list and
then they showed like
larry elders got like oh because they
were trying to keep him off they were
trying to block him from being able to
run he has to like sue or something
yeah yeah because dude if he wins it
would be like the best thing ever oh
thank you it's him and caitlyn jenner
right there
caleb jenner dropped no no she was not
the top but she went to australia for
like
big brother or something oh for a tv
show i guess oh wild
yeah jenner was was polling at four
percent oh okay yep but larry elder
governor of california could you imagine
oh man i'm just going to be very utopian
it's like he walks in and then like
everybody's standing outside waiting to
see what happens
and then they look at their watches and
then also in california is fixed it's
like
it's like all of a sudden everything's
back to normal yeah the poop is off the
streets the homeless people
all instantly the homeless guy sitting
there just pops up and a suit appears on
him it's like whoa
and then he's like got a job and he's
like on the phone he's like i'm gonna
make that sale and
just everything just perfect happens the
poop just gets up and just walks away
itself
yeah it's all magic utility started
recovering plastic and building
3d printing tubes to make geodesic domes
for people to live in
oh i love it great yeah i guess or one
gigantic geodesic dome with little dome
pods
all over the place yeah you break the
plastic down with pestilopsis microspora
fungus and turn it into sugar and then
you mix it with graphene to 3d print the
tubes oh there's graphene perfect yes
all right here we go joe a says my dad
is a landlord and he tried to evict
someone for not paying rent for a year
the town sends the evictions to city
court now and the liberal city judge
refused it has been three more months
since
yes communism that's where we're going
i mean look the the the great reset
people want
people not to eat out not to go to the
stores
not to waste money they want you to live
in the pot and eat the bugs if you're in
the city
and if you're in the middle of nowhere
they want you to have fun playing freeze
tag instead of going to the movies
wow i'm not look i've i've i love
you know climbing and you know i love
sports and stuff so
like i i i enjoy my day when i go
outside and enjoy the fresh air
too many people in these cities don't do
that their their their
their enjoyment is based upon physical
things they can acquire and
uh that's a problem ben stewart was
saying that hanging from a tree branch
for a little bit every day is really
good for your balance really i could see
it
it's good for the back mike g says yes
ian the missing puzzle piece is the
coming market crash
the government needs a smoke screen it's
the kova delta variant crap they keep
pushing
yeah market crash a lot of people have
been saying that's coming and well i
think we're in it
um they take a while they take sometimes
a couple years you know
it doesn't happen one day people don't
realize how the shortages that are
lurking
i warned about the food shortage and now
taco bell is saying it yeah
it's like bro if you listen to my show i
said this like two months ago
look at the local level the local the
local news outlets were like local
chinese food restaurant can't get
chicken anymore
and i was like hey how come the new york
times is reporting this how come we're
not seeing cnn report there's a major
food shortage they don't care
the real money for national outlets is
not in a local story about food
but now taco bell.com international
chain
says at the top sorry we are unable to
get certain ingredients and might not
have your items available
i was listening to a podcast and there
was a grocery magnate who was saying
that we're looking at
inflation of like i want to say six to
14 percent um
and then he was talking about like
breaking down the kind of inflation
we're going to see and he's like it's
coming
like there's no escaping it and i'm i'm
pretty sure that's part of the reason
we're seeing shortages at like taco bell
and like these shortages of meat and
everything but
it's depressing mick dundee says can't
have this argument without philosophy
there are three root arguments logic
emotional
authority needs to be discussed yeah man
you know i've been thinking a lot about
um tactics
and like the gravel institute when they
cheer they cheer on the tactic that was
used by the insurrectionists
but then denounced the insurrectionists
themselves and i'm using
insurrectionists as you know the way
they've described on the left
so the people on january 6 you know
stormed the capital and then gravel
institute was like
they said it was a good thing but they
just disagree with the people who are
doing it
and i've been thinking a lot about this
because i've i've long said
you know the ends don't justify the
means because you'll never meet the ends
if you build a government based on using
violence
and you know and seizing power then you
will just eventually get that anyway
the problem is if people are going to
use those tactics and they work and they
exist it'll never stop no matter what
you do
and thus you end with you end up with
this endless cycle and there's no real
way to fix it
we get a couple hundred years of
classical liberal values and expansion
of civil rights
and then the wingnut crackpots come in
and destroy it all let it on fire to
seize power
and they claim to justify to do it the
founding fathers
won their the liberty and the bill of
rights through
uh violent revolution
yeah i mean the french through the
french emptying their bank account
basically
bankrupting the cops how about how about
we we we say something different in
let's do it the french didn't intervene
in the revolution
the american revolutionaries intervened
in the war between the french and the
english
saving the french okay i like where your
mind's at
yeah france was basically just like hey
we're at war with these guys so you know
anything you need let's say we were we
were basically helping them
you know they helped us we were a
wonderful offshore diversion the enemy
of my enemy is my friend
mr bojangle says france the constitution
forbids the government from
oh and world war ii the constitution
forbids the government from inhibiting
the liberties of the people therefore
the government should be responsible for
ensuring corporations that operate
within the public space
to not limit those same liberties for
the citizen of the citizenry
the challenge is the supreme court has
applied a lot of these arguments
to corporations as individual entities
and that's where the challenge is
to say that twitter has to host the
speech of ian
is is arguably arguably the same as
telling ian he has to say a certain
phrase or a quote by someone else
the issue is we need to regulate big
tech like utilities like like common
carriers more like a phone company
maybe not utility but like a phone
company which is utility i guess
and then they can't take you down
because they have nothing to do with it
except for utility people are telling me
that they can't get texts through about
like a doctor was like i'm a doctor and
my cousin's a
you know a pathologist and i'm texting
him covet vaccine and it wouldn't go
through on his phone
well we already know why and multiple
people are sending me this information
last like four so common carriers even
seem like they're uh susceptible when
the authoritarians take over
funky biden in the dnc said they're
going to the phone company shut them
down
to shut down private text messages mesh
networking
shortwave radio make 1984 fiction again
says
and when those 10 people get their pizza
they realize there's only eight pieces
all hell breaks loose yes no one ever
said they were only ordering
one pizza which brings us to the other
part of that argument is that
in uh in a direct democracy the six
people say we want pepperoni in the
foresee pineapple
and then the six say yeah well we have
the majority rule so we are getting
pepperoni pizza
and then you have like a ranked choice
republic or a parliamentary republic
and the four people say then we choose
to do a pizza that is
two-thirds pepperoni and one-third
pineapple
problem solved two pizzas 25 pieces
yeah and everybody gets two right is
that how it works or you just do
uh they say we're going to do two pizzas
and one
one will be uh half pineapple pepperoni
and the other will be pepperoni and
everyone's happy there you go problem
solved
that's the expansion that's our ability
to expand is
basically what's kept us alive this long
as humans
unspecialized yeah all right
phobes says digital we agreed the social
contract
is not a valid contract i didn't sign
ish and i noticed you've got that red
and black little
youtube image presumably implying
anarcho-capitalism that's right you
didn't agree to the social construct
contract however
there's an interesting argument i have
with libertarians about and and caps
about living in the united states and
it's
sure you're born here it's great to be
here there's a lot of advantages to
being here
but you don't have to be here you you
really don't
i guess the challenge is like where
would i go it's like i don't know middle
of nowhere there's that free state
in um uh in mexico where like a lot of
endcaps
actually go and so i say this to a lot
of people i'm like listen man
like i have i i know people who have
gone to i can't remember the name of the
state do you guys know the state is that
mexican state
it's that one state that's what i was
talking about i used to start with the
ch or something
yeah something like that and it's like
they abolished the government the
cartels and got rid of them and now it's
like totally anarchic
and i know a lot of americans who are
and cap who like go down there like this
yeah luke's always talking about that
and so i say to the people here i'm like
go i'm not going to be mean i'm saying
like that is
like a place where you can live the way
you want to live and have to worry about
it you know what i mean
yeah so if you don't want to agree to
the rules here there are places
you know might not be easy to get there
initially but there are places
you can go and have your own contract
you're an agreement well it's the whole
idea of assimilation you know a lot of
immigrants
you always ask well what do you give up
when you come to america i mean you do
get a lot of things as an american when
you choose to come here as an immigrant
but you also
you do have to respect your culture you
have to respect american structure you
know
american structure is very
individualistic a lot of
chinese immigrants and a lot of
immigrants from asia are not necessarily
used to that
as much you know you do if you want to
make if you want to make change in
america you have to speak up
a lot of asian cultures are not used to
speaking up especially chinese americans
who live under communist regimes
you know it's it's like is it squeaky
wheel gets the grease or
is it what's the other analogy the
loudest
thing gets gets cut or hit oh
yeah you know so you know american
culture is different its structure is
different you do have to assimilate to
that if you want to
you know be be well liked in this
country interesting yeah
all right here's a good one kimberly
brundle says i've been listening to tim
telling us to stand up and do something
to fight authoritarianism
it inspired me to run as a candidate for
the people's party of canada you're
inspiring canadians to fight back
oh foreign election interference in
canada oh oh they're gonna
i thought that was inevitable the one
thing i thought that was really funny
about uh
the 2016 election when they were like
foreign interference and i'm like paul
joseph watson's from the uk and he's
talking about trump
you know milo yiannopoulos is from the
uk and he's here talking about trump
i made a video directly to barack obama
in 2007
saying you're going to win the
presidency you're going to run for two
terms and then steve
grove youtube featured it on the
politics page so like
talk about political interference yeah
what the heck like
got tens of thousands of views like come
on in
ah at least you're an american citizen
yeah it's also like
forward interference are you are you
saying that foreign powers have never
interfered in the us elections ever for
any reason
right they always interfere they love to
interfere russia and china are always
going to
try to interfere you know it's not about
foreign interference about what can we
do to combat it you know
or embrace it and embrace in the guys of
the french
actually interfering to create the
united states that was helpful well this
is crazy
black vikings says botega louis one of
the restaurants you listed has been in
downtown l.a since 1929.
crazy to see it close down wow
that's crazy i don't like that
fritter says dig up the calvin coolidge
quote on perseverance too long for super
chat
a lot of people are questioning our
pizza thing blackrock beacon says ten
voters
six to four pepperoni four agree to seed
to six democracy
but if the four opts to leave the party
and get different food and the sixth
demand they stay pay and eat the
pepperoni
that is authoritarianism hiding behind a
vote that's a great point interesting
yeah so a libertarian system would be
the four people saying
okay then we're going to get our own
food and not eat your pizza
an authoritarian would be like no you
have no choice you have to eat our pizza
and has to be pepperoni
well i think what are you saying so six
people or i was gone for the end of this
conversation six people say we want
pineapple four people four people want
pineapple six one peppers let's change
it around like pineapple
okay whatever six people want pepperoni
four people in pineapple
they end up going with pepperoni that's
authoritarian no no no
it's a democratic it's democracy
democratic authority but you can call it
the tyranny of the majority yeah exactly
it's not
necessarily tyranny if you agree to that
system
right beforehand whatever the vote comes
out as we're all going to agree that's
the pizza we're going with
but what if one day someone walks in and
says let's get pizza
who wants to vote on pizza and everyone
says we'll vote on pizza and then six
say pepperoni and four pay pi
four say pineapple and then when they're
like pepperoni wins the pineapple guys
go we're going to order our own pizza
and get pineapple well then you say
that's not what you agreed to we let you
in here with the agreement that you were
going to go with what we decided so we
decided it
even if they're going to buy the united
states well no if you say beforehand
we're going to buy our own then okay but
if you want to participate we're
deciding but hold on
let's add another element to this they
decide to vote on what pizza to get
and everyone agrees to vote they're all
sitting in the house and says we're
voting on lunch we always vote on lunch
everyone agrees that's how we vote on
lunch okay everyone raised your hand for
pepperoni six dude everyone by chance
pineapple everyone does
and then they say okay we're ordering
pepperoni pizza
and the four pineapple guys go well
we're going to order our own pizza
and get our own pineapple and they say
we need you to pitch in
for the full price of the pizza right
you agreed we'd do a vote you guys lost
but we still need you to pitch in
otherwise you can't get the pizza in the
first place
and they say yeah well we don't want to
pay for pizza we don't want to eat dude
you are here we do this all the time we
vote we all we all share
when you guys got blimpies we ate that
and we didn't like that either
yeah well you know what we know we never
agreed to this okay then
there's the door y'all can leave no
one's making you stay here
but it's cold outside yeah but there's
no food there
okay but i like being in here then you
gotta pitch in don't you
we agreed this is how we would vote on
what to get we can afford one pizza take
it or leave it
well i'm gonna go start my own house
then they go outside and some people
might you know put on that flannel and
take an axe and go be a lumberjack and
build their own house but you know the
funny thing is i talk to a lot of people
and they're like
i shouldn't have to pay for this social
contract and i'm like then you don't
have to get the benefits of being in
america
i'm not saying it to be a dick i'm
saying it's transactional you can go to
uh what's it called chiron
you can go to charon i hear really
really great things about it no i'm not
even kidding i really do hear great
things about it
so go somewhere where you won't have
this be happening to you instead of just
being like i want to reap the rewards of
society i refuse to pay for
now to be fair american tax tax dollars
go to a lot of dumb stuff
that i'm not happy with so well this is
like that's a fair fair point from you
know
people and this is like the case of
affirmative action too because
you know sometimes you have a really
great story and even though you're not
objectively qualified somebody's going
to admit you because of your story
and that would be more acceptable to me
if
harvard college came up to a lesser
qualified person of a certain race and
said
hey you know you're not objectively
qualified but we're going to admit you
but you know we need you to assimilate
to our culture
and you know be grateful but instead
what they do is that not only they admit
you they indulge
your you know every desire with great
inflation everything like that they make
sure that you pass
you know and get a pluses in every class
the average grade at harvard is an a
minus surprisingly wow and it's just
at that point you're not engaging in a
fair social contract
and that point you you are incentivizing
a person to be a parasite on your school
rather than become a person who becomes
fully assimilated into the culture
agreed all right here we go ej pido says
tim will you commit to attending mike
lindell's cyber symposium if you can
secure an invite
he has made bold claims of election
fraud and many of us would like to have
a reporter there we can trust
bannon should be able to set you up i do
not think i would be able to because
with the expansion of tim timcast
comes great responsibility and so
there's a lot of people that i have to
meet with all the time
i work literally every single day
because even even though the weekends i
no longer do this show we're doing the
vlog
and i'm interviewing people one of the
main reasons i reduced the amount of
content i was producing on a day-to-day
basis which was
i used to do five segments on uh on my
tim cass channel and now it's down to
two
because i needed more time to meet with
people and strategize and take care of
other business if my whole all my whole
day was dedicated to just recording and
researching
i had no opportunity to grow so then i
stopped doing content on the weekends i
used to do
i think like three hours on the weekends
as well no like two and a half
and then like four on the weekdays now
it's all
been reduced quite a bit because on the
weekends we fly people
out we do interviews and we film the
vlog there's no way i could make it
however we actually are hiring more
journalists
and we are going to have one of our
reporters covering the election issues
so i will say a lot of people who are
you know like die hard trump supporters
will probably be
disappointed with our coverage however
they were they will not be angry to a
certain degree right
i see a lot of the stuff that comes out
from like msnbc and a lot of these
mainstream outlets and it's just
disparaging and poorly framed and
everything like that
no we're going to be fair which means
air time for the republicans air time
for the democrats
uh and the argument and so our goal is
here's what the republican said here's
the democrat said you decide
we can only give you the information
we're not going to tell you what to
think i'm sure that will be satisfactory
to many many people who aren't getting
that from the mainstream press
and i'm sure we'll get smeared by the
mainstream press for simply entertaining
the fact that republicans have opinions
on the matter
but that's what we'll do so he mentioned
steve bannon steve bannon has a bunch of
reporters who actually go
and talk to the people who are
conducting these audits and stuff so you
should turn to bannon's war room if
you're just that kind of thing
interesting yeah well my friends if you
haven't already give that like button a
little tap
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends you can follow us at
timcast irl on facebook and instagram at
tim cast underscore irl
on tick tock because we are in all of
these places
trying to gain influence and win friends
i can
also put it that way you can follow me
personally at tim cast and of course
we're gonna have a bonus segment coming
up at timcast.com in a little bit
but uh kenny is there anything you want
to shout out your book obviously your
social media
well i'm also president of a group
called colorist united we advocate for a
race-blind
america and that's the ideal that
america should be
right you know i understand we've had
problems with race regarding to america
today but
if any country in the world is going to
finally become a country
where race doesn't have to matter in a
person's life where we can judge a
person
just solely as an individual it has to
be america because we are the most
diverse country in the nation we
have been able to handle this diversity
experiment relatively well so
go to colorestunited.org if you're
interested in this concept and shoot me
a question or link
anything that you want what was that so
more time color color
us united color us united colorist
united dot org
all right in the book an inconvenient
minority in my book an inconvenient
minority
the attack on asian american excellence
in the fight for meritocracy you can get
on
amazon barnes and noble walmart wherever
books are sold
buy it because then when it hits a
number we got uh so i'm not going to say
we have take full credit for this yes we
do
yes michael knowles was like if we get
number one it's because of you guys
no it's because you're michael knowles's
fans keep super chatting us
and sneaking in shouting outside he's
gonna be true none of shabbat is
speechless
by michael moulton i will say though i'm
extremely proud of when i read the super
chat where it told the amazon robot
to order speechless and uh smart
and then people were like i went to my
amazon shopping cart and the book was in
there
but you guys definitely should buy an
inconvenient minority
because when this reaches number one on
amazon
and it should hopefully or when it rises
in the ranks people see it
it's free advertising so it's like a
snowball rolling down a hill
and then when people are wondering what
this is and they read it they'll start
to understand what's wrong with this
critical race applied principles in our
schools thank you tim
thank you kenny thank you tim appreciate
it you guys call me ian crossland.net
and
on social media ian crossland thanks
again i want to read this calvin
coolidge quote because it actually is
super good and i see why it's too long
okay so i'll try to make it quick it
says nothing in this world can take the
place of persistence
talent will not nothing is more common
than unsuccessful men with talent
genius will not unrewarded genius is
almost a proverb
education will not the world is full of
educated derelicts persistence and
determination alone are omnipotent the
slogan press
on has solved and always will solve the
problem of the human race
i actually really like that quote long
as it is wow um so that's
an excellent summary of tim's idea about
grit and the studies that they've
conducted about that
right you guys may follow me on twitter
at sourpatchkids as i uh
excuse me oh no i'm gonna give them more
followers
you may follow me at sourpatch lids do
not follow sour patch kids because i
want more followers than they have it's
my only goal in life right now thanks
guys
we will see you all over at timcast.com
thanks for hanging out bye guys
you